mission subcommittee hearing focusing on
school lunch programs the panel
investigates the current nutrition
standards of school lunches and
discusses future changes of the program
for school children witnesses include
congressional members school
representatives state officials and
executives of health and childcare
industries he'll hear first from
committee chairmen Senator Tom Harkin
Democrat of Iowa this program runs about
three hours and 25 minutes thank you
very much Chris the Subcommittee on
nutrition and investigations of the
Senate agriculture nutrition and
forestry committee will come to order
today we're meeting about the future of
our country and oh like the future of
our country is indeed wrapped up in our
children we hear that stated so
frequently that it can easily become a
cliche a truth honored too often through
lip service instead of through careful
attention and action by the Congress
each of us who has children wants them
to have every chance to reach their full
potential and surely that is a universal
hope of parents everywhere but millions
of children in our nation are destined
for lives which they are forever
foreclosed from attaining their full
human potential for in many cases due to
causes stemming from even before birth
so today's hearing will focus on the
link between sound nutrition and sound
futures for our children mounting
evidence shows that good nutrition
beginning even before birth is critical
to lifelong health and to normal
cognitive and behavioral development one
aspect of good nutrition for children is
the nutrient content and the balance of
the diets they consume such as fat and
saturated fat sodium cholesterol content
vitamin and mineral levels and dietary
fiber these are important considerations
especially for lifelong health since
three out of the four leading causes of
death in our nation have been linked to
diet well deal more closely with these
issues in another hearing that will deal
primarily with the school lunch and
school breakfast programs
but another aspect of child nutrition
has more dramatic and immediate
consequences and that's the problem of
hunger or under nutrition which impairs
health growth physical development and
cognitive and behavioral development and
children the Center on hunger poverty
and nutrition policy at Tufts University
estimated that about 18% of US children
suffered hunger in 1991 again this is
not just an urban problem it's
widespread throughout our country good
nutrition is a sound prevention strategy
against a host of serious and costly
health problems including infant
mortality premature births low birth
weight and Nemean just to mention a few
and it's also a good way for us to save
money
studies have shown that each dollar
invested in the WIC prenatal assistance
saves from a dollar ninety two to four
dollars and 21 cents in Medicaid costs
in a study that I requested the GAO
estimated that the initial investment in
the WIC prenatal benefits of two hundred
ninety six million dollars in 1990 would
save about 1.3 six billion dollars in
health and education expenditures over
the next 18 years undernourished
children simply do not learn as well as
they should the president really
recently signed the goals 2000 education
bill which had as its number one goal
the first one that every US child enter
school ready to learn but without proper
nutrition from even before birth our
children simply will not be ready to
learn and good nutrition also means a
better educated more productive and
capable US workforce and finally and
perhaps most noteworthy of all that
fighting hunger is as chairman Leahy
said many times a moral issue and a test
of our conscience as a nation when we
recognize that each of our nation's
children is too valuable to write off
the poverty and hunger we do justice to
the best in all of us
unfortunately with the tight federal
budget we have little additional money
for expanding these nutritional programs
all though I am hopeful that we'll find
enough money to at least keep the WIC
program on track towards full funding
but in these circumstances you must
really continue ly to ensure that we're
making
the most effective use of federal
dollars and to look at ways to improve
that one example of making better use is
competitive bidding for infant formula
Senator Leahy and I put this in place
several years ago and in fiscal 1994
alone competitive bidding is expected to
save nine hundred thirty million dollars
and allow 1.5 million more participants
to take place with the money that we are
saved so we also need to look for
innovative ways to combine federal money
with private efforts I'm pleased to have
a number of excellent witnesses here
today before I turn to our witnesses a
table I would ask my friend and my
colleague from the state of Idaho for
any opening comments that you might have
mr. chairman thank you very much both
you or the committee of the witnesses
and the audience will be probably
relieved today that I have laryngitis
and will probably be listening more than
talking but I do appreciate the effort
that you and your staff and the
Chairman's staff have put into these
hearings both this one and the one we
will have in a few weeks on the school
lunch program you've been very
accommodating to allow other senators
requests of various witnesses to appear
in panels that will all be hearing from
this morning and that's very much
appreciated instead of making a
statement let me suggest to all of you
this morning who will testify a series
of questions that I will be asking that
I think are fundamental to anything we
do here especially as we create public
policy that will drive programs that as
the chairman has just said will have
profound impact on our children and our
children's future so here are some of
the questions that I will be asking you
this morning what are the specific
scientific sources that support your
statements what specific scientific
sources that would support or refute
your statements made either in this
hearing or other hearings of our public
statements on your area of expertise
please make available your personal
knowledge and experience from studies
and research on the specifics of the
bill under consideration by the
committee
because as we continue to review this
subject we must review the total diet in
relation to what government should and
should not be doing what is the
government's responsibility and then
again what is the individual
responsibility as a relates to education
exercise and the diet the reason I say
this is that we're not involved now at
this moment or in the formulation of
this public policy involved with
political science or being politically
correct
let us there on the side of
well-established science laboratory
science the kind that has come from our
universities from our medical research
centers the kinds that dietitians and
doctors and professionals nationwide
would recognize to be good science and
not the political science that we
sometimes get captivated by as the
trendy thing to do at the moment in time
public policy should not be founded on
that kind of politics thank you very
much mr. chairman Thank You Cindy Craig
ranking member senator Mitch McConnell
Thank You mr. chairman
I appreciate very much your holding the
hearing today mr. chairman the
reauthorization process is well underway
and I think it's both timely and
important that we hold this hearing to
further explore these important issues
researchers have made great strides over
the last few years
discovering the impact that various
foods or food components have on our
health we now know that consuming too
much fat and saturated fat can lead to
heart disease too much salt as bad for
your blood pressure that both but most
fruits vegetables and fibers can help
prevent health related diseases the
question we face as members of this
committee is how do we work this
knowledge as scientifically valid
information we have into our federal
nutrition programs we've worked hard
over the years to provide assistance and
nutritious foods to our citizens in need
both children and adults to the young
and old and I might add that we've been
successful in doing so
we spent over forty billion a year on
our federal nutrition programs and we
reach literally millions of Americans
this reauthorization process provides us
with a time to look over the programs
and improve upon their administration as
well as the policy that pervades these
programs I'm pleased to see that we have
a list of witnesses before that will
bring to the table valuable experience
and and knowledge of nutrition dietary
needs of children as well as dietary
habits of children childhood development
and the intimate details of the
nutrition programs and how they impact
their targeted populations as we
consider ways to improve the programs
and the nutritional well-being of our
nation's children's children two
thoughts come to mind first we've all
heard the old Chinese proverb give a man
a fish and you feed him for a day teach
a man to fish and you feed him for life
to me this quote though used in a
variety of settings tells us of the
importance of education and in our
situation of nutrition education if we
teach our children and adults attendance
of healthy eating the importance of
moderation of diet the values of
nutrients and food components then we
will build a healthy population
nutrition education is not a new concept
in both public and private educational
efforts have been effective
you can just tell just by going to the
grocery store that the new nutritional
labels show the change of focus on the
national level to nutrient intake and
the number of low sodium nonfat and low
cholesterol products that are on the
shelves have grown exponentially I know
there are people that need to be reached
in our efforts that the school level
will continue as new classes come
through the doors the second point I
want to make is that we as the federal
government have a role to play and a
responsibility to all citizens but I
firmly believe that the government
should leave consumption and behavioral
decisions in the hands of the individual
not of a federal bureaucracy nutrition
programs are some of the new of the few
government programs that as a Republican
I like but it concerns me that Big
Brother could start to control our
eating habits then I
thing you know a fat tax could be the
new way to help fund these programs we
should be providing the education sounds
like a good idea to me yeah I know you
like that thought right thank you
darling to the IDS guys would go with at
where the Twinkie tax keep talking old
Tom never met a taxi like especially
especially upon the kind of people that
we're talking about here to push fat on
kids they ought to be taxed we should be
providing the education the knowledge
the means for giving the individual the
ability to make his or her food choices
these nutrition programs do not operate
in a vacuum and we should not expect
them to nutritional habits are not
solely dependent on what people learn in
a classroom but they're affected by
other societal factors as well finally
just to touch briefly on two programs
this hearing will highlight today first
is the child and adult care Food Program
and I want to welcome Linda Locke the
executive director of four C's in
Louisville my home town I know she's
going to speak to the entire program
that she will also discuss a
demonstration project that's been
tremendously successful in Kentucky back
in 1989 I introduced legislation along
with my friend of mine come out right
here senator Harkin to initiate a
demonstration that tested a change in
the eligibility criteria for this
program because of this demonstration
around 7,000 kids 57% of whom are
low-income are now receiving nutritious
meals under that particular program and
Linda has been instrumental in helping
to carry out the project in Kentucky
second we will explore wick wick is a
program that has enjoyed bipartisan
support from this panel over the years
I've sent letters to my colleagues every
year for the past six years urging that
they continue on the road to full
funding of WIC and just to
parenthetically our recent learn
recently learned the first WIC clinic in
the country was in Pineville Kentucky in
the heart of Appalachia
we conclude one more quote there's no
Greek proverb that says you cannot
reason with a hungry belly it has no
ears we're about to hear how science
backs that statement up we have
witnesses today that will discuss
the nutritional needs of our children
and the important length that we know
exists between cognitive development and
sufficient nutritional nutrient intake
we're all looking forward to hearing
these suggestions and recommendations
the witnesses and exploring how we can
reform our nutrition programs to reflect
the priority of raising healthy children
Thank You mr. chairman
thanks Emma come and now a distinguished
chairman of our Agriculture Committee
who has really taken a lead in our
efforts to combat hunger and
malnutrition focus on these issues I can
remember when the Senate changed hands
back in 1987 and Senator Leahy became
chairman of the Senate Agriculture
Committee and our opening meeting
everyone was waiting to hear what the
new Chairman would talk about in his
opening statement to sort of set the new
tone and temper for what the AG
committee would be doing and I can
remember very distinctly Senator Leahy
talking about agriculture and support
for agriculture but he started off this
whole talk by saying that the
Agriculture Committee would pay close
attention to and would focus on the
issues of nutrition and hunger WIC
programs and how we get our kids started
off on the right foot and he's followed
through on that he's been a great leader
of this agriculture committee in hell
but he said in 1987 he's proven up on
and I'm just proud to serve on the
committee with him Senator Leahy thank
you senator Harkin I must say as
chairman the committee having made
nutrition matters my top priority
because with particular gratitude that
Senator Harkin is willing to chair this
this subcommittee because he's part to
improve expand the programs involving
child nutrition and has joined with me
on some of the foreign aid programs but
dr. Brazelton I see you wearing one of
the Children's Defense Fund ties I have
that same one and
how important is it's not just children
here but children throughout the world
and I must say a Senator McConnell as
ranking member not only this
subcommittee but also the subcommittee
handles all foreign aid has been a
strong fighter in those same issues and
Senator Harkin of course be reliant him
very much not only here but also known
as key role in the Appropriations
Committee for that but we've made a
bipartisan thing of it senator lugar the
ranking Republican on this committee
been strong supporter Bob Dole and I
have either sponsored or co-sponsored 20
years now virtually every major
nutrition piece of legislation here and
I put my post Dave on the record because
these are the people we want to hear
from but I couldn't help but think
earlier this week I was talking about
the new plans for school lunches and
I've gotten back the night before from
Normandy and motional was all the d-day
celebrations were in Normandy and
probably one of the most moving
emotional things I've done in in my
years here in the Senate I couldn't help
but think that two years later President
Truman signed into law the first school
lunch bill and in it he said it was part
of our national security because they'd
had so many other recruits who came in
malnourished with rickets with all the
other problems that went with that and
he said we ought to have part of our
national security to have a school lunch
program that works and we did and 25
million meals a day are served in this
country that's more than the population
of a great number of countries the point
though is that unfortunately even today
in many of our schools that is the only
will milk these children gap and we can
not only make them better meals we can
teach them better nutrition
they'll be healthier our nation will be
healthier they'll learn better and these
are the children are gonna live most of
their lives in the next century and are
going to determine what that century is
what bothers me is that we may do away
with the malnutrition that we're seeing
the early 40s but it's the
undernutrition that dr. Sagan and dr.
Brazelton are going to talk about that I
think is robbing America of its future I
mean these told our future they're going
to determine what kind of a nation we
are in the next century and I think that
we have to make sure that we eliminate
the undernutrition and I'll close with a
point I've made over and over in this
committee in a nation is wealthy and as
powerful as the United States the only
major power in the world able to feed
all its people two hundred and sixty
million people and still have food left
over for export is not right that we
have hunger and undernutrition and
malnutrition in this nation of all
nations blessed as we are and it goes
beyond being a social or economic or
even national security issue it's a
truly moral issue and I think that we
should all realize that because there's
not a person in this room I'd be willing
to wager goes hungry except by choice I
guarantee you we could walk outside this
door and walk just a few minutes as we
could in any building anywhere in this
country
and you find people don't have that
choice so I thank you for being here mr.
chairman I applaud you for holding these
hearings thank you very much for this
kind words
chairman Leahy and for your leadership
on this issue we have a distinguished
colleague from the state of Washington
senator Slade Gorton who has always had
a keen interest in support in these
areas and we welcome him as our leadoff
witness senator Gordon Thank You mr.
chairman for giving me this opportunity
before the subcommittee
on a program important to me to
thousands of children and my state into
hundreds of thousands of children around
the United States I want to speak for a
few minutes and to provide
recommendations for the reform of the
Summer Food Service Program the Summer
Food Program as you know is designed to
give children in impoverished
communities healthy lunches during the
summer months last year I had the
opportunity to have lunch with children
at the daffodil elementary school a
summer food sight in Puyallup Washington
that day I saw what an important part
the program plays in the lives of
children across the country not only
does this program provide healthy
lunches but it also provides children
with opportunities to play and make new
friends which ultimately makes for
happier summers for all of them during a
meeting with the Washington State
administrators of the program last year
however I learned that the program
administrators could not let children
take cookies or apples or the like away
from the site because of federal
regulations prohibiting the practice it
makes sense that this regulation applied
to the perishable portions of the meal
those items most susceptible to
foodborne illnesses but what does not
make sense so to this day FNS has not
given me a satisfactory justification
for the broad scope of the regulation is
the application of the regulation to
those lunch items which do not pose a
risk of foodborne illnesses snack items
like cookies apples oranges our wastes
that are thrown out because of the
regulation it's a prime example of a
regulation calling for serious review in
an attempt to focus new thinking on the
subject
I helped include report language in the
1994 agriculture appropriations report
directing FNS to take a closer look and
to work with local administrators of the
program to figure out a way to address
the problem of food waste unfortunately
for the children and local
administrators FNS only partially
addressed the issue of food waste at its
sites finally after a lot of prodding
from my office last Wednesday FNS issued
some policy guidance to local
administrators on ways to avoid food
from being wasted at the site
but it still has not told administrators
to my satisfaction how to allow for
minimal or item-specific off-site
consumption I'll provide the new FNS
guidance to the subcommittee for its
review I'd like to work with the
Committee on a solution to the problem
posed by this broad regulation and ask
that it consider including language on
the subject in the legislation to
reauthorize the program that's by first
subject my second stems from the
realization that the committee is
operating under tight budgetary
constraints and is doing its best to
keep the reauthorization bill free from
new funding I do offer a proposal for
the committee's consideration however
that I believe to be a good way to
complement the Summer Food Service
Program my proposal would be subject to
appropriations and as a member you know
with the chairman of the Terek no I'm
not you re on AG subject estimating okay
the Subcommittee on agriculture
appropriations I understand the
difficult funding constraints which we
are presented with this year and in the
years to come
not unlike other communities across the
nation rural Enderlin the Summer Food
Program is helping kids get good meals
during the summer months but what about
the hours before lunch after lunch is
over where did the children go do they
head back to empty homes because a
parent or parents are working hard to
make ends meet what are their summers
really like one summer food site in my
state came up with a way to answer these
questions
it was contacted by the summer food site
administrator in Kent Washington she
estimates that nearly 100 children
between the ages of 6 and 12 will
participate in her program this year
with the support of volunteers the local
police department in the school district
she plans to keep the summer food site
open from 9:00 in the morning until 5:00
in the evening the site will be open for
kids to play games and will provide
tutoring and other learning
opportunities for the children during
the day sounds like a wonderful way for
children to spend their summer days in
fact when some of the parents learned
that the summer food site would be
providing tutoring and other learning
opportunities they said they would drive
their children or take public
transportation
to the site to give those children the
opportunity to keep up with their
schooling I can't think of a better
reason for the committee to accept this
provision problem is that keeping these
sites open requires additional funds
this administrator estimates that she
needs twenty thousand dollars to run an
all-day site through the summer I offer
the committee a proposal to authorize
and all day activities demonstration
project the demonstration project would
be based at an approved Summer Food
Service Program site and the
administrator would be authorized to
award grants of up to $25,000 to such
sites if they meet specific eligibility
requirements in order to qualify a site
must provide adult supervision of
activities show community support
through local community sponsorship
volunteers funding or other means
provide learning or tutoring
opportunities for the children and
operate the site of the activities for
not less than seven hours during each
day of operation the grant funding could
be used to carry out activities
necessary to support the all-day
operation of the site including
transportation to and from custodial
services staff support of the like I
want to make clear to the committee that
I see this proposal is strictly a
demonstration project the legislation
before this committee is a four year
reauthorization bill I propose that we
use this four year time period to
demonstrate to local communities service
clubs small business groups and other
organizations that they should sponsor
through funding and donations
these all-day activity sites in the
future will demonstrate to local
communities the wonderful opportunity
these sites provide the young children
in their formative years urge the
committee to include my all day
activities demonstration project in the
legislation before the committee today
thank you very much mr. Chung thank you
very much senator Gorton and I know
we've discussed this in the past and I
compliment you on your interest in this
area in your proposal any I agree with
you any way that we can find
associations private entities where they
can join forces to extend these and
these things out we can get more bang
for the buck that way and
I look forward to working with large you
know whenever we got a lot more bang for
the buck you know when we provide seed
money to basically private organizations
than we do with one that we just pay for
a hundred percent ourselves with
government employees in many cases
that's true especially in this area that
you where the Hawaii five-o program
Hawaii is abolished latchkey children by
taking responsibility at the state level
for paying for any access to program
that shows its merit and they have
literally cut down on acting out on the
kind of things that we know these
latchkey kids get into in a significant
way you might want to look into thank
you I didn't know that either hi I'm
Senator in a way about that
thank you sooner and did anyone have any
questions for Senator Portman thank you
thanks Larry thank you very much senator
well just as they predicted we have a
vote at 10 o'clock and go and come right
back
well we could start and juggle this
thing around
are your schedules such dr. Sagan dr.
Brazelton that you could wait oligo vote
and come right back
I really want to prefer to have as many
committee members here as possible I
yeah I'm glad to wait if you had waited
for it cuz I don't want to miss any of
your testimony and and so we'll just
call a short recess maybe about between
10 and 15 minutes we'll be right back
we could the subcommittee will please
come to order
I'm sad to announce that the floor
people running the floor advise me we
may have more votes this morning I the
best laid plans always go awry I guess a
I've always tried to schedule hearings
on Friday when we don't have any votes
so wouldn't you know it this Friday we
have all these votes coming up we'll do
our best and persevere we are very
privileged and honored to have two
distinguished individuals leading off
our panels this morning both of whom are
distinguished in each of their own areas
and crossover into a lot of other areas
I just must say at the outset anytime I
see an article anywhere either with the
Carl Sagan's name as the author or Terry
Brazelton I read it because I can't
think of two individuals that I admire
more for their clarity of thought and
purposeful writing dr. Carl Sagan is the
David Duncan professor of astronomy and
space sciences and director of the
laboratory for planetary studies at
Cornell University he's played a leading
role in the Mariner Viking Voyager and
Galileo spacecraft expeditions to the
planets and is known for a scientific
work in both astronomy and biology is
the author co-author editor of more than
20 books his Emmy and Peabody
award-winning series cosmos became the
most widely watched series in the
history of public television dr. Sagan
is a 1994 recipient of the public
welfare medal the highest honor of the
National Academy of Science received the
Pulitzer Prize the Oersted medal and
many other awards for his contributions
to science literature education and
preservation of the environment dr. T
dairy brave T berry Brazelton has was
born in Waco Texas and graduated from
Columbia University College of
Physicians and Surgeons he it became a
co-founder of the child development unit
at Children's Hospital in Cambridge
Massachusetts he has published more than
180 scientific pay
has written twenty four books on
pediatrics and child psychiatry one of
dr. Brazelton foremost achievements in
pediatrics is his national behavioral
assessment scale he is now a clinical
professor of pediatrics emeritus at
Harvard Medical School and an active
member of the child development unit at
Children's Hospital in Boston both dr.
Sagan and dr. Brazelton serve on the
Advisory Committee to the nutrition
cognition initiative of the Center on
hunger poverty and nutrition policy at
Tufts University and we welcome you both
here and I'll start with house lined up
my book I'll start with on my left here
with dr. Carl Sagan again welcome back
to seven committee and proceed as you so
desire Thank You senator Harkin may I
say I share your admiration for dr.
Brazelton Thomas Jefferson said if a
nation expects to be both ignorant and
free in a state of civilization it
expects what never was and never will be
it's a class of social problems where a
relatively modest early investment as an
enormous payoff later
ignorance is such a problem the cure of
course is education but education often
is not enough there is recent evidence
that malnutrition and undernutrition are
long overlooked and important factors in
determining the ability of children to
learn a recent national survey done for
the Department of Education paints a
picture of a country with more than 40
million illiterate or barely literate
adults other estimates are much higher
depends on the definition of literacy
the literacy of young adults has slipped
dramatically in the last decade the vast
majority have no idea how bad their
reading is only four percent of those at
the highest reading level are in poverty
but 43 percent of those at the lowest
reading level are
although it's not the only factor of
course the better you can read in
general the more you make and you're
much more likely to be in prison if
you're illiterate or barely literate my
testimony today comes the delivered
written testimony senator Harkin comes
from an article that I wrote with
andrian in the March 6th 1994 issue of
parade the two of us come from families
that knew grinding poverty but our
parents were readers one of our
grandmothers learned to read because her
father who is a subsistence farmer
traded the sack of onions to an
itinerant teacher she then read for the
next hundred years she died at the age
of 103
our parents followed prescriptions on
childhood nutrition recommended in the
1930s by the Department of Agriculture
as if they were handed down from Mount
Sinai and I remember this book on how to
take care of your children from the
Department of Agriculture on its last
legs with pages scotch tape back
together again and in a position of
great respect in our in our household
for a while my parents gave up smoking
which were one of the few pleasures
available to them in the Depression
years so as an infant I could have some
vitamin and mineral supplements
I wish actually they had continued that
but Annie and I were very lucky for that
reason recent research shows that many
children who do not have enough to eat
wind up with diminished capacity to
understand and learn what is these days
called cognitive impairment children
don't have to be starving for this to
happen
even mild undernourishment the kind that
most common among people in poverty in
America can do it it can happen before
the baby is born
the mother isn't eating enough can
happen in infancy it can happen in
childhood when there isn't enough food
the body has to make kind of decision
about how to invest the limited
foodstuffs available to it and survival
comes first growth comes second and in
this kind of nutritional triage the body
seems obliged to rank learning last it's
sort of better to be stupid and alive
than smart and dead but the net result
is that there are possible severe
learning impairments from having not
enough to eat instead of showing an
enthusiasm a zest for learning as most
healthy youngsters do and which is a
tool of our survival
the undernourished child becomes bored
apathetic unresponsive and more severe
malnutrition leads to lower birth rates
and in it's absolutely most extreme
forms to smaller brains what was once
considered relatively mild under
nutrition is now understood to be
potentially associated with lifelong
cognitive impairment children who are
undernourished even on a short-term
basis they have a diminished capacity to
learn for the rest of their lives and
millions of American children go hungry
every week also just parenthetically
lead poisoning which is endemic in inner
cities also results in serious learning
deficits I think Senator Leahy was
absolutely right when he said that this
was a national security problem because
when millions of children grow up with
diminished capacity to learn it affects
all areas of the nation including the
economy some programs that have been
wisely instituted on the federal or
state level deal with malnutrition the
special supplement food program for
women infants and children called WIC
WIC the school breakfast and lunch
programs the Summer Food sir
program all of these have been shown to
work all of these are connected with the
legislation before your committee
senator Harkin although they don't get
to all the people who need them I'd like
to just read a passage from the recently
published book starting points meeting
the needs of our youngest children
published by the Carnegie Corporation of
New York on WIC participation in WIC
they say reduces by 15 to 25 percent the
chance that a high-risk pregnant woman
will deliver a premature or low birth
weight baby it increases the likelihood
that these women will receive early
regular prenatal care and that their
children will get regular pediatric care
and immunizations mothers and children
who are at greatest risk those who are
poor minority and poorly educated
benefit most wix cost-effectiveness has
been clearly demonstrated because it
significantly reduces the chance of
prematurity and low birth weight and
thus avoids extraordinary costs of
neonatal intensive care that these
conditions typically entail the savings
can be substantial the average cost of
providing WIC services to a woman
throughout her pregnancy is estimated to
be less than 250 dollars the costs of
sustaining a low birth weight baby in a
neonatal intensive care unit for one day
are many times that amount
despite its demonstrated success however
WIC has never been fully funded it
currently serves about 4 million women
and children out of an eligible
population of seven million and I very
much hope that the Liberation's of this
committee can push the availability of
WIC towards 7 million in its early days
this nation had one of the highest
perhaps V highest literacy rates in the
world of course women and slaves didn't
count in those days as early as 1635
there had been public schools in
Massachusetts political theorists came
from other countries to witness this
national wonder vast numbers of ordinary
working people who could read and write
and debate and our
you our devotion to education for all
propelled discovery and invention of
vigorous democratic process and an
upward mobility that pumped our economic
health today for various reasons
including undernutrition of the very
young the United States is not the world
leader in literacy nor is it the world
leader in infant mortality in fact it's
at the low end of the industrial nations
and how many of our babies we managed to
save many of those judged literate are
unable to read and understand very
simple material much less a sixth grade
textbook or an instruction manual or a
bus schedule or a mortgage statement and
the sixth grade textbooks of today are
much less challenging than those of a
few decades ago while the literacy
requirements at the workplace are more
demanding than ever the gears of
undernutrition
poverty ignorance hopelessness and low
self-esteem all mesh to create a kind of
Perpetual failure machine that grinds
down dreams from generation to
generation we all of us bear the cost of
keeping this machine running and
illiteracy and the extent that it
contributes undernutrition is the
linchpin of this failure machine even if
we were able to harden our hearts to the
shame and misery experienced by the
victims the cost of illiteracy to all of
us is severe the cost in medical
expenses and hospitalization the cost in
crime and prisons the cost in special
education the cost in low productivity
and in potentially brilliant minds who
could help solve the dilemmas besetting
us even if we didn't have a microgram of
compassion in us it would still make
sense to take heroic steps to avoid
undernutrition and malnutrition in
fetuses infants and children
and to make reading available and
attractive to all Americans this will
not solve all our problems but it will
take us far
senator Harkin that's the end of my
prepared statement I did want to just
make a remark to Senator Craig who asked
for some scientific underpinnings and
I'd like to perhaps add to the record or
at least give the senator Craig the
statement on the link between nutrition
and cognitive development and children
prepared by the Center on hunger poverty
and nutrition policy Tufts University
which has some nice scientific
references in the back that objection
will make that a part of the record -
thank you very much dr. Sagan dr.
Brazelton again welcome back to
subcommittee and again please proceed as
you so desire well thank you senator
Harkin I'm delighted to be here with you
guys and particularly with one of my
heroes Carl Sagan but mr. Craig you have
my 9 months old grandchild in Sun Valley
as one of your constituents so I want to
be sure you do right ah him doctor and I
have one other comment doctor I can't
testify to what he's eating but I can
tell you the air he's breathing is very
healthy ok well let's keep it that way
Jerry the other thing I wanted to say to
Senator Leahy was that I wore one of
these Save the Children ties to the
White House and Hillary said who bill
has one like that and I started to say
bill who and then that's true then you
remember but they they're prevalent but
it is a great pleasure to be here and to
have an opportunity to talk to you about
not only the deficits of a feeding
problem I have a feeding program but the
opportunities that might be associated
with it and I was thrilled to hear
senator Gorton talk about what could be
tied to feeding programs and
not just additively but synergistically
when you tie feeding and something else
like cognitive input or emotional input
you're getting a synergistic effect not
just a simple additive effect and I
think that is maybe what we all are
looking for now in these times of rather
desperate funding and so forth well I've
been a pediatrician for over 40 years
I've seen 25,000 children run through
Harvard and MIT and so forth where I
practiced and most of them were
middle-class or working class so I
really didn't until I went over to
Harvard to teach full-time wasn't as
aware as I have become sense of the
power of undernutrition on children's
affective development of activity but I
didn't have chances to look at this
across culture and just to go back to
what US for senator Craig the first
opportunity I had was in Guatemala and
with paho and American Health
Organization and the World Health
Organization and they were studying a
series of families that were being
raised on the eastern slopes of
Guatemala who were on a nutritional diet
of 1,400 calories a day at a time when a
pregnant woman probably needs 2,200
calories and we could tell you
successfully by the babies behavior on
the first day our second day whether the
mother was on 1,400 calories our 1800
the baby's behavior was so significantly
affected and this struck us and we began
to give them a supplement called
terrible-tasting supplement called I've
even got in kappa Reena and the mothers
wouldn't take it the mothers who were
under chronically undernourished were
anorexic and anorexia turns out is a
protective factor if you're chronically
undernourished you're really not that
hungry and so unless we tied with the
anorectic with it supplement the reason
for taking this if you want a smart baby
if you want a baby that will do whatever
their goals might we could identify
might be they wouldn't take
supplement if they took it at all they
take it home and spread it around the
family as any mother would do if she had
four or five children so just giving
people the opportunity for supplements
our food stamps or whatever is not going
to work the way we want it to however if
you take that as an opportunity to tie
it to some cognitive or emotional reason
that makes sense to the recipient then
you get the effects that we've seen from
WIC and for my money the reason WIC is
work is that it gives credit back to
these poorly served under underserved
populations by saying this is why it
works this is why you're doing it you
have it in your hand we give them back a
self-image as well as a supplement now I
would look for that in any of the food
programs you're going to be after I
would look for that chance to get back
into the system of outreach and give
them back something in the way of a
self-image and it's so easy to do it we
know how to do it it doesn't take a lot
of time it just takes attitude and WIC
is a is a prime example of that Head
Start is to both of the two successful
national programs have included parents
as their goal that what we learned in
Guatemala though is very significant
that these babies whose mothers were on
1,400 calories if we compared them to a
group that were supplemented up to 2,000
calories not only was their behavior
different but their head size was
different and the postulation was that
is as much as 40% of the number of brain
cells that might have been there through
DNA replication were not replicated
under the effects of malnutrition and
since that study we have learned a lot
more that you not only have less cells
the brain that's been undernourished
through pregnancy but you have smaller
cells more vulnerable to the normal
events around labor and delivery of all
infants go through hypoxic periods in
labor and delivery if you have
vulnerable cells you hit something and
you make and it sticks now the other
thing we've learned is that the brain is
sparser not only smaller and fewer cells
but Sidman at Harvard has shown that the
immature brain cells start in one part
of the brain and migrate to their final
resting place under the effects of
malnutrition or chemicals like drugs or
heavy smoking there they stop
significantly less times as they find as
they migrate and you have a normal brain
a normal baby will stop stop stop stop
stop and set up dendritic connections
with the rest of the brain under the
effects of these deprivation systems are
chemicals you have significantly less
stops and so you have a sparser brain
and one that doesn't really work quite
so well and we at the age of school-age
the studying Guatemalan kids that we
were studying had 10 to 15 IQ points
difference and you could say well that's
not very much is it well it is if you're
on a borderline and if you have a ninety
or a hundred IQ and are trying to
function in school it makes the
difference between success and failure
and what we saw in the neonate was
exactly what I think we see on street
corners and all and already if you'd
pick up a normal the innate and holding
with his head here at his bottom here
and say hi are you doing come on you can
turn to my voice come on you can do it
any normal knee and it will stop moving
its face on it they'll turn your voice
and when they find out where it's coming
from
they arch forward like hey there you are
and if I put a mother over there and we
both talk any newborn will pick the
female voice turn to her face look her
in the face and she automatically I've
never done this yet with a woman that
didn't grab her baby and say you know me
already like it was a miracle I even do
it with fathers now if they tell me
they've talked to their fetuses as they
wouldn't you like to play this game and
fathers also you know they won't know me
you know macho types but when I can get
them to do it 80% of babies to their
fathers voice is over mine and the other
20% I tip their head so at that point
ah every father does but the mother that
grabs in says you know me so this
behavior on the part of the baby and
they're 26 of these in the neonate
capture the environment to that baby and
make them not only attached more
significantly but understand that baby
in our research understand the baby's
cues and are locked into that baby in a
significantly different way right
straight through infancy and childhood
and we have some stuff here from Howard
University with unwed fathers that show
that if you can hook them in the in the
neonatal period that those fathers stay
significantly more attached to their
their babies but also to their babies
mothers to whom they're not married and
it's seven years these kids have a
higher IQ and a better sense of humor
about that for an outcome so we are
talking about not only cognitive
acquisitions but emotional acquisitions
that are up that give you that you have
an opportunity at now if you do the same
thing with these undernourished babies
in Guatemala and hold them just like I
told you that baby will arch frown turn
away spit up have a BM turn blue around
the mouth show you in every system
you've overloaded me and if you pick
them up to hold them on your shoulder
and most babies will pick their heads up
nestled in the corner of your neck these
babies are too way from your slip
through your arms so every neonatal
behavior that a mother our Father
depends on for attachment gets turned
into something negative in these
undernourished kids and they're like
sacks of meals are hypertonic or show
you
mild CNS disorders that are interfering
with their behaviors that would capture
the environment too now that we found in
Guatemala that if you said to one of
these mothers with a baby like that how
often do you feed your new baby they
would tell you oak when ever she wants
it if you stayed in the household
o'clock that it would be three times per
24 hours in the next few months
when catch
might have occurred now if you go back
to that sparse brain and you add to it
something that we just come to in the
past 10 years that there's fantastic
plasticity in the human nervous system
it's the plasticity is out of proportion
to anything any of us ever understood or
look for or now have an opportunity to
supplement and if you give a brain
that's been sparse it's like that are
even insulted the opportunity it will
call into action
redundant pathways in the immature
nervous system that would drop out in
the next year and a half if we didn't go
after them but can be brought into use
and put to use to supplement the
behaviors that might have might have
been impaired we see that in blind
babies by their hypersensitivity to
auditory tactile kinesthetic we see it
in all kinds of babies and now in the
epidemic that we're seeing in crack and
cocaine babies we think that 85% of them
if these this plasticity were respected
could be brought into a system in which
we could recover them so we're seeing it
in all sorts of ways but undernutrition
is one of the main ways this can happen
and of course it's usually associated
with other toxic chemicals or with other
things that go along with it so that
coupled with poverty which the most of
these kids are born into should become a
real target and of course if we could
get there in pregnancy and bring people
in to the system and get them prenatal
care we would cut out as all of you know
and we all hear all the time
Carl talked about it we would cut down
on prematurity on the kind of impairment
that we see in babies that we don't get
to in pregnancy so pregnancy ought to be
our first go our second goal could
become the newborn baby
and could become the small baby at each
of his stages and development when
parents are so available for you when a
child's learning to walk any parent
needs somebody backing them up
that kid screams all night all day
drives mothers up the wall they're ready
to throw their kids against the a street
corner and if somebody's there to say oh
isn't it great he's going to be on his
feet in another month a mother can get
through that without a crisis and she
can make it now if we set our feeding
programs up to reach out for people and
bring them in at these appropriate times
in their infants development and in
their development as parents I think
we'd be reaching people that we'd have
no concept of reaching at this point and
I would like to urge you to think about
your opportunity around the feeding
program the other things that we've
learned is that the babies that are in
our face-to-face research we do research
with small babies and their parents in
what we call an attachment paradigm and
we put them out in a baby chair and then
have the parents go in and play with
them and for two minutes and set up an
expectancy for interaction and by three
months the baby and the mother are going
oh and the mother go how you doing the
baby will you and the mother go come on
give me another and the baby is second
time if we violate that that expectancy
which we set up in two minutes and then
send the mother in with a perfectly
still face and she starts and it won't
respond to that baby in two months
minutes we're finding some very
disturbing things that girl babies whose
mothers are depressed or undernourished
or poor if if those three are in place
and the mother has been interacting in
an unpredictable or withdrawn way in the
first three months the the girl babies
will sort of give up and turn away and
gaze evert boy babies get violent at
three months and by six months it's very
clear that they are not going to put up
with this kind of in unpredictability
from their parents and we think we're on
the track of the earliest indication of
violence and wit and these are
undernourished hopeless unreached young
parents who set up this kind of paradigm
with their girl versus boy babies I
think this is really important to think
about now if we use this nutritional
paradigm to reach out try to bring these
people into the system couldn't we
change that paradigm the next indication
that I'd like to point out to you is
that it Children's Hospital in Boston we
can tell you which kids at nine months
expects to succeed and which expect to
fail by their behavior at nine months we
can we can make a separation between the
ones that are going to make it and the
ones that aren't and the way you do it
is given two blocks and show them they
can bang those two blocks together a
baby who expects to succeed will take
one block and drop it and see if you'll
pick it up for him when you pick it up
he tries to tease you again and you say
go on put them together and he crowns
and puts them together and then he looks
up at your life aren't I great now that
kid is already on a success bet you give
that to a child who's under nourished
who doesn't feel good about himself
who's never been supplemented or who has
some of these learning disabilities that
Carl talked about that come from
intrauterine our post utero and
malnutrition those kids take the two
blocks
Dulli put them close but then make them
slide by each other and then comes the
symptoms they look up at you like hit me
again I'm no good and then at 12 months
when you show up out of pile to on
together they knock one off and then
comes the symptom at 15 months when they
walk across the room they trip and you
say what do you trip on and then he cows
and looks up at you like this at 18
months he makes you want to strangle him
and then comes that cow look which makes
a surge of anger arise in the recipient
of this look so I'm just saying this
because I think these kids tell us very
early we can we not only can recognize
kids that are on
this event but we can change it if you
take these learning disabled kids are
these kids with attentional disorders
and incidentally they have quadrupled in
the past ten years in this country you
know that four times the number of
learning disabled kids and part of that
is recognition but part of it may be
that the increase of stress in our
society is paying off in these kids with
learning disabilities and hyperactivity
or attentional disorders if you feed
them appropriately before you ask them
to get into a learning situation they
change significantly in front of your
eyes
now we're talking about disordered
nervous systems that are having to
compensate having to overcome
interferences but with with nutritional
supplements they can make it and I would
say this is a real challenge can't we
pick these kids up and say these kids
need something special and then I go
back you know to your your question
about do we want the government to be
doing this we've got to have the
government say this is important and
then we can turn it at each level back
to people who can see that it gets
implemented in a very personalized way
because it's got to be done in a
personalized way but I think the
opportunity to do this has been already
demonstrated by WIC by defeating the
school feeding programs and I I'm here
just to point out that if we don't do it
and you know I go back to William Wood
heads comment when somebody said well
isn't it ought to cost a lot to do this
and he said compared to what the cost
out here is going to be so much greater
than anything we put in down here I just
don't think cost had better stop us up
thank you
well dr. Brazelton thank you very much
very very provocative and I mean that in
a good sense provocative statement
because it provokes thinking and I think
you provoked the reactions I think in
all of us who are sitting up here I am
you mentioned you said that pregnancy
ought to be our number number one goal
in other words I take by that you meant
that focusing on prenatal care for
children as the number one goal I didn't
misinterpret that is that right and
secondly newborns a second goal you
realize I'm biased I understand that and
agenda let's take let's take the second
one first on newborns we do have the WIC
program it's been a successful program
we know that we know all the data is we
tested on have to go over that again
could you talk for a few minutes about
the role of breastfeeding and what role
breastfeeding should have or should not
have it is an important factor is it
something we have to be focusing on what
are your thoughts on how we ought to be
focusing on breastfeeding for newborn
infants well again you get me as a
biased person I think any pediatrician
would would immediately be biased Pro
breastfeeding because it carries well I
don't need to go in should I go into all
the things that it carries with it go
right ahead
good I think again I know it's
repetitive but I think it bears
repeating because I think it's that
importantly too it carries with it a
kind of milk that was made for humans
and milk that's been made for cat for
cattle are calves is different and it
places a different kind of physiological
demand on the developing organism
fortunately for all of us cow's milk
works but it does it carries with it a
very slight but real cost and to some
kids who are allergic to cow's milk it
carries a lot of cost so breast milk is
is the optimal and we even give it now
to bear
a high-risk prematures when we're trying
to wean them over from intravenous
feedings to oral feedings and they have
either a short cut got this very
hypersensitive or whatever we start out
with little bits of breast milk and we
can get away with it they fed a baby at
the Children's Hospital the other day by
mistake a little bit of formula the same
amount we've been given breast feed to
the breast food to the breast milk to
this baby all the way along baby went
into shock so these vulnerable kids show
us the kind of leeway that we're working
with so breast milk is certainly
appropriate it carries with it immune
systems that I mean immune bodies that
are very appropriate particularly these
days when otitis media and recurrent ear
aches are becoming our major one of our
major health problems in infancy and
breast milk certainly helps protect from
ambient infections the other the main
thing I guess and they're probably
others in the audience that can go
through a whole list is something that I
feel very strongly about in the area of
attachment of interaction and of the
shaping of the baby that I was talking
about in this face to face thing that we
do that we see so much shaping going on
by the environment the breast milk is a
wonderful wonderful way as mothers who
are working all day say I've got to wean
I can't do this and I say gosh come home
at the end of the day and you've been
away all day and you pick up that baby
and get close again isn't that wonderful
well the thing that is so exciting was
something we did a long time ago when a
baby is sucking they suck suck suck suck
suck suck when they're hungry for about
a minute or two suck suck suck then they
fall into what's called a burst pause
pattern they suck suck suck cause suck
suck suck suck suck suck pause and
anybody who has a baby with a bottle
will jiggle them at that point to make
them eat out of if the baby's at the
breast the mother will go come on
and tickle the mouth or say keep going
keep going
and you say to the mother what did you
do that for this is the pause and she'll
say oh I want him to keep going so we
did a study
Kenneth K and I did a study on the
pauses where the mother or the nurse did
something and the pauses where they
didn't and the pause is where they did
something were longer than the ones
where they did nothing so their goal is
to get the baby to eat the baby's goal
is to get the scratching and in the talk
with the mother and the closeness and it
was fabulous as soon as you could point
that out to a mother she begins to pay
attention to those puzzles she said this
is the best time isn't it and she begins
to talk so breast feeding becomes this
rhythmic interactive system in which I
don't think any parent can not respond
to any sensitive parents so it carries
with it some very subtle important
messages beyond the nutritional ones and
of course I feel that about nutrition in
general was a strong proponent of
breastfeeding and I have been all of my
adult life having served in various
capacities on different entities dealing
with the promotion of breastfeeding in
this country and around the world it has
always been a struggle on my part again
also being a strong proponent of the WIC
program which of course provides infant
formula to leathers and to low-income
mothers who may not have the proper
information although now we've done
something in the recent past to provide
an educational basis and we'll hear from
some people later on about that to get
information out to low-income women that
breastfeeding is the best way to go and
should do that but it's always a tough
battle because well they can get that
infant formula and it's there and
especially if they see ads these
wonderful ads with this very beautiful
woman usually dressed in very fine
garments and a wonderful beautiful
setting and the images that that
portrays that somehow if you feed
formula you can be like this woman in
this wonderful setting and everything
and there's that there's that kind of an
impact
it goes out on low-income women and I
just wonder if you have any thoughts
about the need for better education to
go along with the WIC program now I
don't want to deny anyone the access of
course to formula but and and we've seen
studies done in the program that show
that if low-income women during their
term of pregnancy get the right amount
of information and education on the
benefits of breastfeeding and perhaps
even little incentives after that if
they will breastfeed maybe they'll get
some incentives in terms of other food
supplements that they can get they'll go
to breastfeeding absent I just wonder if
you have any thoughts on that that's
sure do and I think it goes back to the
same thing that when I was on the
National Commission for children with
Jay Rockefeller and we came up with all
of the statistics that we came up with
in our book which are actually are the
same as they came up with at carnagie we
realized how that we were the least
child and family oriented society in the
world but we could point to two programs
that really changed that image one was
WIC and one was a head start and to me
the two carry with them not just what
their goals are and then Wicked's
nutrition in Head Start its education it
was the way they were done and the way
they were reached out for and I would
say that with WIC the main you could if
you tried to pull apart whether it's the
nutrition that's making a difference to
that baby's development or the backup
for the young mother I'll bet you would
find it was it was weighted in the
direction of what the mother gets when
she comes in and people are trying to
and capture her and teach her how to
nurture so I would go after it that way
and I would I would say that with a WIC
program ought to be aimed at promoting
breastfeeding with women who can listen
and can hear you and give them
supplements give them all the kind of
backup that we know how to do
and the ones who can't then back them up
for the for the kind of adjustment they
have to make if you were going to back
up a woman who is breastfeeding and she
had four other kids at home I would use
the WIC supplements to be to give to
those other kids so she felt less guilty
about doing so well by this baby but not
so well by the for at home and there are
many innovative things you could do like
that if your goal was to reach people
not just to feed them and I think that
that would be where I would suggest that
WIC go next particularly if you're going
to try to cover different ethnicities
and and different layers of society and
that's what I hope you're doing thank
you very much I have some questions I
want to propound to dr. Sagan but I will
yield first to my ranking member mr.
Chairman I just want to thank both of
the witnesses for a very very impressive
testimony we have a lot of witnesses and
I'll not pose any questions but I do
want to thank you both a extremely
impressive say we go there to carry mr.
chairman
now I applaud you but also the
beneficial for the introduction of 16-14
and I would say that in Nebraska and I
suspect Nebraska is not unique at least
in this regard the most troubling issue
before adult citizens today is the
status of our children particularly at
lesson children recent published report
that did an evaluation of health and
safety factors nationwide published by
an organization called Kids Count
Nebraska rated fifth in the nation
safety and health factors all things
taken into consideration but there were
three statistics that revealed that even
in a state where there's good news there
are significant problems and statistic
number ones and this is from 85 to 91
the rate of violent crimes perpetrated
by children between the age of 10 and 17
increased 36 percent out of wedlock
births teenage births increase 34
4% and 2 and children teenage children
who are neither working nor in school
also increase 30 3 or 4% I mean I I see
too large in addition to headstart and
WIC to really large American tax funded
mostly institutions that we've created
too
on the one hand provide an education as
our K through 12 environment and in the
other hand to try to provide good health
or as I would say it a treatment of
sicknesses as opposed to necessarily the
development of health but nonetheless
they both proximately the same size we
withdraw from the gross domestic product
annually about four hundred billion
dollars for each one in the form of
taxes property taxes sales taxes income
taxes all sorts of things and we
organize these institutions in much
different fashions and it seems to me as
I look at the institutions that what
occurs is that I will spend anywhere
from five thousand dollars in a hospital
environment where the costs are
relatively low up to twelve thousand
dollars in the district to deliver a
baby because twelve thousand dollars
used to be 2-day normal vaginal delivery
now the payers are picking up the tab
for one day mostly if I was a woman I'd
protest that policy but that's a
separate issue to day normal vaginal
delivery twelve thousand dollars down to
five thousand dollars or so for delivery
of a child and then the child is sort of
gone and if there's a head start program
a work program based upon categorical
need they can go and get some assistance
but essentially we wait until they show
up in school five years later with the
very problems that you've identified
and increase either because we're doing
a better job of identifying I suspect
not either both because we're doing a
better job of identifying and because
there's increased stress and tension and
the family for all kinds of other
reasons with the tension deficiencies
and hyperactivity and learning
disabilities of all kinds and you know
if dr. Brazelton as a physician I
appreciate if it's possible I know if
you're doing QA at this point mr.
chairman are you're just doing opening
statements or any question saying okay
one of the things that it troubles me
about our healthcare system is if I give
some condition a definition that
typically occurs that after the
definition funding follows so for
example if an adult suffers some sort of
cerebral damage let's say stroke we give
it a name of the stroke and we then
mobilize a very impressive
multidisciplinary rehabilitative effort
to try to help that adult get back to
the home and so forth I mean it's very
impressive the multi the new
multidisciplinary efforts to help that
stroke victim it's got a name health
insurance companies will pay Medicare
pays we're really a constant
descriptions of what we do need to do to
improve the quality of care for
individuals who are stroke victims but a
child leaving a hospital seems to me
from what you've said has a brain that's
continuing to develop for what another
24 months they're every bit as much at
risk as that stroke victim but we don't
give it a name we haven't given it a
medical definition as a consequence no
funding occurs so what we have to do is
beg for special categorical grants for
WIC and for Head Start and so forth the
healthcare institutions don't respond
now I'm not suggesting that that that in
the healthcare community there's no
alien molinere instincts quite the
contrary we heard a very moving
testimony yesterday on rural healthcare
from from a family practitioner in
Kansas describing an incident
we're two o'clock in the morning he goes
down and delivers a baby and all the
sorts of things that he went through I'm
not suggesting that there not be any mas
know but I do know that like all of the
human beings if there's payment made
it's much more likely that the care is
going to be provided and I'm I'm very
much interested in your ideas on how and
whether we should change the rules of
financing by perhaps describing that
baby when it leaves the hospital in all
cases almost at risk because it seems to
me they are at risk we look for all
together too often labels to place on
at-risk kids and it seems to me that
other 3 million live births that we'll
have in America today that they're all
at risk that they're all extremely
vulnerable for a 24 month period during
which the brain develops and even though
if I love the the word insult if the the
brain suffers an insult I wonder if
that's what's happened to all of us but
I I'm curious as to what not you have
any ideas on how we might in this health
care debate change rules of financing to
provide incentives to to minimize that
risk
well yes I certainly has some ideas
again they come from a strong bias but
of prevention and one reason have gotten
involved in the health care planning
with mrs. Clinton was to keep
reinforcing the fact that prevention
will save us enough to pay for all this
out here but also prevention has an
opportunity to do something way beyond
anything we're doing right now and I
would even hope that this nutritional
supplementation that you're talking
about could be incorporated into a
preventive system if we got it going in
the proper way and I've testified for
Chris Dodd and his committee and I was
followed by a pediatrician who pointed
out to me that something very critical
that unless we point out what we mean by
prevention very clearly in the in the
front-loading it's all going to go to
the elderly because the AARP is so good
at it
and so I think we've got to be very
careful if I could interrupt I'm not
sure so much the AARP is the medical
community there's no there is no
comparable to the word stroke on that
infant when that when the miniature and
the baby leaves Hospital there's no
comparable word that because it's
applied I now have a multidisciplinary
response to make sure that there's job
training health care all sorts of it the
mother and father and I think it had
better be at a conceptual level that
that kids who've been through either
intrauterine or post you to run stress
are at high risk and it better be paid
attention to and I've been fighting to
have four opportunities in the first
year thirty minutes each interspersed at
each interval in which only the only
attention to the kid is not
immunizations or a physical checkup but
how the child is developing and how the
parents are relating to that child and
we can do that it wouldn't take us for
thirty minutes and we could have one
sign to each clinic doing that and we
would then have a fix on the kids that
are developing in a deviant way our that
is showing us some of these precursors
that we're aware of now that might lead
to violence drop out learning
disabilities hyperactivity all of the
things because we do know now how to
identify those kids early and if we do
couldn't we start the intervention back
in there in just the way you suggest but
that would mean we'd have to pay some
attention to it in a way that we haven't
so far exertion thank you senator Kerry
I plan to have senator lugar here minami
I didn't - thank you sir no sir expect
to see senator crane or senator lugar I
appreciate your being here
let me ask because I I appreciated your
statement dr. Sagan illiteracy and I
would like to ask of both of you for
thoughts about strategies of getting
information to these mothers we've been
talking about in these first months
clearly the amount of information about
nutrition is more and more abundant
sometimes argumentative and
contradictory but still abundant it's
not clear that we've devised ways in
which the people most at risk mothers
and the infants that we're talking about
our recipients of this and some of it of
course is governmental responsibilities
or through the contacts with
professionals but I but both of you are
remarkable communicators gifted with all
of multimedia that we have available in
society I I would just be curious as the
strategies that you would emphasize if
we were to allocate dollars just for
communication and for information on
these vital topics I was saying earlier
it's anted Lugar about how in my
childhood my my mother treated as if it
had been handed down from mount sinai a
Department of Agriculture book on how to
how to raise and take care of your your
children was the first one done in the
30s but she could read and here we have
a cycle
in which if you can't read and you don't
know this information how does it get to
you and it seems to me if I were in your
shoes in trying to really push this I
would go to a range of unconventional
methods I would try to encourage
churches to communicate to their to
their people to their ministers to in
sermons and in Sunday schools the
importance of such nutrition I would try
to get it on MTV I would try to
encourage rap music about it
I think the issue is so important that
it really is worthwhile doing more than
just issuing press releases and then
saying well we've done our our job there
are a lot of people in the entertainment
industry for example who I think would
be willing to cooperate if approached in
a sufficiently flamboyant way and and
it's not very difficult there are as dr.
Brazelton was saying all sorts of
built-in human predispositions in this
direction I mean women do have a
predisposition to to hug and breastfeed
and love their children it's just a
little encouragement needed and also on
the question of perinatal malnutrition
if there are sources of food available
to the pregnant mother then it's not
just enough to say here it is you have
to explain why it's important and why
it's important for the health and
well-being of the child the future of
the child and everybody is concerned
about the future their children I think
would be like pushing an open door but
it has to be pushed I would add add to
that the ethnically sensitive and
socioeconomically sensitive out
innovative
programs that we have turned up in the
past year starting with the choices
offense funded then all of the people
represented in this audience we've been
doing outreach we we found how little it
takes you know I think it's amazing how
little it takes to reach out into a
community and capture people for their
children and maybe not so themselves but
for their children parents as teachers
is one of those where you bring in
somebody from the community who talks
the same language has the same value
systems you give them a little bit of
training I'm on their board and I didn't
think it would work at all it has worked
because they go back into the community
round people up for just what we're
talking about and they do it I saw this
in action in Juarez the other day
because the El Paso has realized that
their half million population is
dominated by the healthcare in the one
and a half million across the border
what they've done is capture all the
elderly women in the community that have
respect of people send them out and drag
these young women in with their children
every day it's very successful so I
think we have ways of doing it now and
if we're sensitive to ethnic differences
to socio-economic differences and really
have the heart behind it I believe
people be more responsive than we've
ever dreamed of it certainly has been
true and WIC thank you very much thank
you mr. Sherman Thank You senator that
was a was a good question got me
thinking about it too nice pretty good
Thank You senator great chairman thank
you doctors so thank you very much for
your both impassion and I think very
accurate statements as to nutrition as
it relates to child development and and
and the phenomenal value that it has my
colleague from Kentucky who has now left
and I and all of us on this panel but he
was the one who mentioned it I've
struggled for a good long while
recognizing that WIC is a quality
program but with but that we struggle
with resources to fully fund it and
we've never really ever done that and
dr. Sagan you mentioned that large
number out there that are
but the larger number or a larger number
that are not served my question to both
of you if you had to sit in our shoes
and make choices and we have to make
choices
if those choices had these kinds of
components one to change or modify the
WIC program to expand its
characteristics or its roles for example
some will add suggest that it ought to
get beyond supplemental feeding now two
additional foodstuffs or to fully fund
that which is currently the program if
those were the two options
what would you opt for based on your
experience and knowledge I should say
that my experience and knowledge on this
issue is far inferior to dr. Brazelton
and I would gladly defer to his comment
but it seems to me if there are seven
million eligible people for WIC only
four million of whom are being provided
the most urgent thing is to provide for
those remaining three million and then
upgrading what is available to all seven
million might be the next step and the
kind of of triage choices that members
of the House and Senate have to have to
make is agonizing and always in this
narrow manner that is the choice here
was not between going from 4 million to
7 million or buying 3 attack helicopters
that's not the choice and that's
probably roughly the the exchange value
because that's a different committee
maybe some of you are on that committee
but but the the structure does not
permit backing off and looking at at the
overall interests
and here I would say again this is a
question of national security versus
another issue of national security and
what is the proper mix I personally
think that 270 billion dollars plus
hidden costs in the Department of
Defense budget with the poor
malnourished children out of a enough to
eat that is an imbalance strictly in the
context of national security
thank you doctor I would of course I
couldn't agree more with what Professor
Sagan's just said I would say that I
would like to see you put more emphasis
on in WIC on the opportunity for
capturing these people for not only the
system of outreach systems that I hope
we're going to have in place with the
health care preventive system and others
that I hope we're turning toward in this
country but capturing them for the
system but also giving back to them a
sense of I know how to do it for myself
and for my kids and so by the time
you've got two supplementary foods if if
you've done it well enough in the
beginning you have innovative women like
when I saw the other day chewing up
supplementing foods and spitting it in
her six-month-old babies mouth like the
Greek woman from the Greek islands why
not and you know here she was she
couldn't afford to buy food baby food
but she could afford to chew up her own
food and give it a vision of a grow and
that kind of self-image I would say
would be what I would be aiming for and
the supplements that we were giving her
would be just part of that and I would
like to see the programs really aimed at
of a human component you're suggesting
that if there's modification you might
weight your experiences slightly toward
that my own bottom is that a properly
sized I'd almost say to them look either
you can do this as well our men
this place isn't worth it maybe we go to
somebody else and supplement them but I
guess that's a little bit punitive and I
hate to do that with anything is
important it's wick so yes I would
certainly say that what new resources
we're going to put on this we want to
see go into reaching out for people in a
way that's going to increase their sense
of responsibility and self-image and I
feel that about all of the things that
are about to happen on the hill and they
can be done either punitive lis are
supplementary ly and if we go after
welfare right now and do it punitive ly
we're going to do more harm than good if
we did it in a supplementary way we
could do a lot of good so I feel that
about the food supplements that you have
in your hands you know thank you
gentlemen
Thank You senator Craig and just for
just a couple three observations one
we're hoping obviously that the Family
Medical Leave bill that was passed as
I'm the law will promote better use of
breastfeeding because now women will
have some time off and hopefully be able
to use that time to to breastfeed
secondly I appreciated senator Lugar's
question on the outreach and the
communications that is most difficult
you had some good thoughts on that let
me proffer two other perhaps thoughts on
that we've had testimony in the past on
two different types of programs one was
up I'm sorry I can't remember the name
of it I asked my staff we can't seem to
quite put our fingers on it dick maybe
you notice where they use like
grandmothers of the same ethnic racial
background religious background to come
in and they use grandmothers they're not
professionals or anything like that and
they come in and and do that kind of
counseling for young mothers it's been
very successful where it's been tried
I'm sorry I can't remember the name of
it the second is a offshoot of a program
that I have seen work wonders it has
been a very successful program they're
very small the F net Peaks expanded food
and nutrition education program again
when they take young women low income
extension service runs States and they
teach him how to buy groceries how to
cook meals how to plan a menu how to do
all these things in the nutritional way
and once they get them going on it then
after a couple three or four years then
they use them as the teachers like a
peer counseling kind of thing and so if
we can I'm just thinking as you're
talking about these women who have
successfully gone through you know
breast feeding who have interacted with
their children now their children are
healthy and well-adjusted use them I
think as as pair counselors for some of
these young women I think we have to do
more of that perhaps in terms of this
outreach and communications to bridge
that gap so I just offer those because
they've worked in other areas but I
don't know that we've tried them that
much in this area is there anything else
either one of you would like to comment
on or two to leave for the committee
before we just like to make one one
remark and that is there are lots of
statements by members of both parties
these days about the need for Family
Values resurgent Family Values I hope
that every member of Congress who uses
that phrase is a strong supporter of
improved nutrition available -
especially to poor children and
especially pregnant mothers and infants
because while you need food whether
you're part of a family are not your
ability to function in a family way
especially when you grow up depends very
much on on that and essential
constituent of of being able to be a
functioning human being and so I just
hope everybody who's used the phrase
Family Values is encouraged to vote for
this I appreciate it thank you very much
doctor saying dr. grace I just like to
say that I've testified a lot down here
but I've never had as exciting a time
and the feeling that you
no people like you were really listening
and paying attention so I hope the rest
of the Senate is is a waken listening to
you thank we we hope so and I hope we
can call on both of you in the future to
help us out in these endeavors
thank you dr. Sagan dr. basis thank you
very much we'll turn to our second we'll
turn to our second panel here dr. Doris
Darrell Ian from fabric California miss
Susan Kalish executive director of
American running and fitness Association
from Bethesda Maryland miss Harriet holt
cloud professor of nutrition at the
sparks clinic University of Alabama and
if we could ask someone from our third
panel miss Linda Locke director of
public policy community coordinated
childcare from Louisville Kentucky to
also join this panel we'd appreciate it
again we welcome you all to the
committee and thank you for traveling
great distances to be here all of your
statements will be made a part of the
record in their entirety if we could ask
you to sort of summarize it and I always
have said that the best testimony is
that which you can just focus in on what
you want to say and what what would you
want us most to leave here understanding
and knowing from your standpoint you can
do that for us I'd sure appreciate we'll
just start as I head them on the list
here dr. Doris Darrell Ian did I
pronounce that correctly
I know Durrell Ian Ellison I'm sorry I
apologize sorry Durrell Ian from
Fallbrook California president-elect of
the American Dietetics Association start
with you dr. Darrell thank you I would
like to move up the childhood cycle to
classroom I'd like you all to focus your
attention on being in a classroom at
this moment beetron or Brenda or Lewis
or whatever the people that I have in
fact done my research on I am very
interested in exactly the quantitative
and qualitative effect of hunger on
classroom activity classroom behavior
but more important academic performance
right now it's 11:30 and you are
probably experiencing everyone in this
room whether you ate breakfast or not a
condition called transient hunger it is
not dependent on whether or not you are
well padded in terms of your economic
condition it also doesn't matter whether
you're well padded or not it simply
means that at the time at which you
physiologically are responding to the
need for food you are experiencing a
competitive psychological constraint
called hunger and as an adult you have
developed a compensatory behavior you
are able to accommodate your hunger to
get through this hearing to get through
a vote to get to do whatever you need to
do as an adult that's part of adult sets
of behavior however I have been looking
at what happens to children who do not
yet have compensatory behavior and who
are the effect of hunger as a
competitive psychological condition
keeping them from learning I am NOT the
only person
has done work in this field there are a
number of people I'm the first person
who's done it actually in the classroom
rather than removing children and
studying them in a clinical environment
I've actually been in a classroom and
measured the degree to which they are
unable to complete academic tasks it's
interesting that in this country we will
give children all the things they need
pencils textbooks safe buildings and yet
for some reason we have a condition in
which we question whether or not we
ought to be serving children a breakfast
and a lunch on site I find that very
interesting I consider food to be part
of the educational process and I can
tell you right now that my data and
other data suggests that there are three
or four academic deficiencies in
children who are experiencing transient
hunger the first one is they make more
mistakes their scores on validated tests
are lower because of two reasons they
make more mistakes on the problems they
attempt and they quit the task sooner so
they have more incomplete problems less
creative answers etc so their test
scores are significantly lower other
people Meyer and others have looked at
the question of attendance and it turns
out that children who do not eat
breakfast for example simply have more
days in which they do not come to school
or are tardy and when they do get there
if they have not eaten they are in fact
the effect of that hunger which
interferes with the kinds of academic
demands that are their job and after all
children's job is learning and if they
have any competition with that they're
going to pay attention to that competing
feeling when I asked children what did
you eat I got an incredible range in a
in a sample size of 600 kids you can
imagine I got some incredible morning
meal intake statements the thing that I
found most interesting was a huge intake
of caffeine now in a sample of 600 kids
more than 300 kids had had some caffeine
containing beverages offi teas sodas and
so for
well if you add that what each kids I'm
sorry would third graders eight-year-old
across racial we had school districts in
Southern California that would
represented a lot of different
demographic characteristics of the
children but it's interesting to note
that when children don't eat and they
have some caffeine containing item that
even exacerbates the problem so that
their blood sugars and their energy
levels are reduced back to fasting very
quickly in the morning I'm particularly
interested in the morning meal because
in most academic settings in elementary
school
most of the hard subjects are included
for children in the morning and that's
when they're least likely to be
adequately supplied with food energy and
appropriate intake in terms of stomach
contents etc nutrition the degree to
which we are using the school lunch
program is quite successful and I think
we've seen now great attention by you
and others on improving the quality of
the school lunch program what I am
finding is that the school breakfast
program which simply does not have the
same level of participation either
because the programs do not exist across
all school lunch schools and secondly
because the participation is lower in
fact substantially lower and my feeling
is that we can now measure the deficit
that is a result of this hunger
condition across all socio-economic
categories school breakfast and school
feeding is often considered to be a
program for low-income children but I
will repeat in my data and in others
particularly pilots who use only middle
and upper-class children and his work
that the effects of hunger on academic
performance across all socio-economic
levels and I think when we're looking at
whether or not our kids can acquire the
kinds of academic problem-solving and
technologically advanced outcomes that
we're looking for to produce a better
America we have got to feed children
either at school or support that kind of
thing to a greater degree thank you
thank you very much Center
Elian actually go to susan Kalish
executive director of the american
running and fitness Association bethesda
maryland and i have to turn a Dick Lugar
on this one he said he's our great
runner your light is to have Susan here
as you know I've been proud to serve as
a member of the board of that
Association and have great interest in
their testimony good
thank you very much chairman Harkin and
other distinguished members for allowing
me to address you I'd like to send a
special thanks to Senator because I just
pull the mic in really closer
senator lugar he's been a guiding light
to all of us in the fitness community
not just to my board but to everybody
he's a good role model and also he's
shown a lot of interest and support and
we truly appreciate it
he said I'm Susan Kalish and I'm the
exact structure of the American running
and fitness Association were a nonprofit
education organization of about 15,000
recreational athletes and sports
medicine professionals who come together
to disseminate accurate
easy-to-understand information on diet
training and health we were founded in
1968 by the Surgeon General of the Air
Force dr. Richard Bohannon to educate
and motivate people to exercise the work
of your committee is extremely important
to the fitness community for too long we
fear that exercise and physical activity
has been busted Side is just fun in
games when in fact exercise can truly
work wonders to improve the quality of
all Americans lives
another myth we'd like to debunk is that
children are getting enough exercise
that's just not true
thank you changes in the activity status
of Americans can have positive effects
in many areas if you look at some of our
biggest problems crime drug abuse
teenage pregnancies directing health
care costs there's scientific evidence
that exercise can make a positive impact
in all these areas you see people who
are fit are less likely to get involved
in crime and drug abuse girls who are
active or play sports almost likely to
become teenage mothers on the average
medical claim of a sedentary American is
twice as much as that of a fit American
so you can see the ramifications are
quite large just for exercise
um in fact when we talked about children
40% of the children between five and
eight are obese have elevated blood
pressure and high cholesterol levels and
they aren't active enough always factors
for heart disease the number one killer
of their parents at least 50% of our
American children do not get enough
exercise to strengthen the heart and
lungs just like their parents and 40% of
all boys and 32% of our girls in high
school smoke or to tobacco a proven
caller for cancer in their parent
physical activity whether it's running
biking walking swimming rowing flashing
you name it improves both the physical
and mental well-being of children each
year researchers are finding that
exercise combats another third symptom
of aging or that diet cuts your risk of
another disease you'd think armed with
these facts that kids would be getting
more fit but they're not in fact there's
a dangerous trend in the opposite
direction a third of our children don't
engage in sufficient physical activity
to give them any aerobic or endurance
benefits children 6 and older weigh more
and have more body fat than they did 20
years ago on right now over two-thirds
of our children don't meet the minimum
standards for cardiovascular fitness and
that number keeps increasing a child
under 10 spends 200% more time watching
TV than sweating and being active if you
think it would be easy to blame our kids
for this with Nintendo and junk food but
in fact that's not fair children are a
reflection of us their parents and
reflection to society and its priorities
Nats we focused a little bit on school
lunches and nutrition I hope your
committee could focus a little more on
physical activity in the schools did you
know that only one state Illinois
mandates daily physical education did
you know that close to 40% of children
in grades 1 to 4 instructed in PE less
than 30 minutes a week and on an average
less than 9% of the PE class is spent
actually being vigorous that works out
that the kid who has it 3 times a week
for 30 minutes a shot we're talking
about eight minutes of exercise in the
schools a week um what can be done there
are a lot of things that can be done
on that physical activity and recreation
be an option when y'all are putting
programs together say in public housing
include space and incentives for
recreation you'll find that less
vandalism and also there will be
improved health among the tenants during
the LA riots one of the few areas that
was actually destroyed with the rec
centers people liked them people wanted
to be there um food assistance programs
we talked over earlier I really would
like to see some educational components
in RAL if we can arm the parents with
the right information we can really true
work wonders fitness and sports
activities can be filled in a lot of
different areas and frankly the
President's Council on physical fitness
and sports they're dying to get involved
in this area working with HUD and with
HHS in different areas if y'all would
just ask oh another point about the
council I'd like to make I work closely
with them and did you know that as more
and more studies are supporting the
importance of physical activity our
government agency on sports their budget
is getting smaller and smaller every
year the public looks to the council as
a fitness place in government but with
so many cutbacks I can't really make
much of a mark on government programs
and finally I feel education like I said
before is key to change the way
Americans think and act we need to
educate them y'all do as well we did a
super job with a National Heart Lung and
Blood Institute at NIH they did
outstanding work helping reduce heart
disease and cholesterol and now we can
see that kind of results in our health
care well how about if we do something
like that in physical activity I mean
that works let's pick a new subject and
keep going at it because Americans can
take responsibility for their health if
we just tell them how to do it um thank
you very much I appreciate it
um if we can help in any way let me know
thank you miss Kelly Shaw next uh
witnesses
Harriet holt cloud ms cloud is the
grandmother of feeding kids with
disabilities she's a professor of
nutrition at the University of Alabama
Birmingham she will describe the meal
modifications that children with
disabilities require and the obstacles
they face in participating in school
meal programs
morning and members of the subcommittee
I just a slide interpretation of the
word grandmother does that I said that
sort of lightly does that mean grand
mother I am a professor at the
University of Alabama in Birmingham a
registered dietitian and a nutritionist
who works at the Civitan International
Research Center and sparks clinics which
is one of the University affiliated
programs in the United States
established to Train graduate students
in working with children and adults now
with developmental disabilities mental
retardation and many special healthcare
needs and I'm very grateful for the
opportunity to present some testimony
and comments related to better nutrition
for this particular population of
children in all of our nutrition
programs but with special emphasis today
on what can happen with school food
service I don't know if you realize that
probably 15% of all children of the
pediatric population now it is estimated
our children with special needs and we
include in this group children with Down
syndrome with other chromosomal
aberrations with seizures with cerebral
palsy the neural tube defects that
despond bifida cystic fibrosis inborn
errors of metabolism particularly PKU
and other many other conditions which
lead to children who are hungry children
who are undernourished and who have
feeding problems also children who have
problems with obesity our national
surveys have indicated that probably 50
percent of that 15 percent population
are at nutritional risk and the they may
be children who have altered energy
needs they may have higher energy needs
or they may have lowered energy needs
and it definitely affects their ability
to participate in many of the child
nutrition problem program
such as school lunch and school
breakfast for example children with Down
syndrome usually require lower meals at
lower in energy value than is generally
standardized in the school food service
program there are children who attend
child nutrition programs that I have an
interesting syndrome called prader-willi
syndrome
these are children with uncontrollable
appetites and obesity and controlling
their food intake and preventing that in
obesity is one of the most significant
health factors in their life on the
other example another example of
children these children with special
problems who are in our schools and in
our child nutrition programs are the
children with inborn errors of
metabolism particularly let me talk
about PKU PKU is an inherited disorder
where the child is unable to eat foods
high in protein they cannot have meat
they cannot have milk they cannot have
milk products they have to have a
closely monitored diet without this
their intelligence is is greatly
impaired if they're not treated from
birth on with a special formula they
will be grossly mentally [ __ ] but
they require this formula and this
treatment throughout their life now it
used to be that we said on the inborn
errors we stopped at age 4 no longer the
scientific evidence indicate that that
is important and then there are children
who are very underweight or we call them
in nutrition lingo failure to thrive
who require extra calories which will be
provided by extra fat and carbohydrates
in their menu many of the children with
cerebral palsy fall into this category
and as also as we think in terms of the
Dietary Guidelines coming into the
school system these are children who
will not respond well to provide dairy
guidelines now how do we meet the needs
of these children well first of all we
need to have a medical prescription sent
to the school there is regular there are
regulations in existence now that that
require that each of these children must
be met
the problem is that the two schools have
not always been ready for this challenge
and the community has all not always
known that they could refer children
into this program therefore many times
the menus have not been met have not
been modified to meet the needs of these
children and their food needs are just
simply not met and it probably reflects
the lack of training on the part of the
school from service personnel rather
than unwillingness to do something about
this these children also need to be
included in special education into
nutrition education programs
particularly as inclusion becomes part
of the special education programming for
these children another consideration has
to be for modifying the texture of the
meal many of these children cannot eat
the regular school food service meal and
therefore the texture has to be modified
it may have to be chopped it may have to
be blended it may have to be pureed but
it needs modification attention has to
be made to the cafeterias where these
children seat are seated and making sure
that they have special equipment for
seating and eating and finally in that
regard we're now seeing children who are
being too fed in schools as these
children in our school system there is a
great necessity for interaction between
all programs serving these children i
enclosing want to express the
appreciation of the nutrition community
for the statement in May of 1990 I think
it was in May but in 1991 senator Dole
on the floor of the Senate related to
this the needs of these children that
were not being totally met at that time
subsequent to that we've had a lot of
action going on and there are now
training programs underway they are sort
of in the beginning stages and they need
a great more reinforcement but the
overall pervading need is to make sure
that we don't forget these children in
our planning and in our programs at all
levels but today I'm particularly
focusing on school food service thank
you cloud thank you very much for your
saving I will yield to Senator McConnell
to introduce our next Thank You mr.
chairman I've enjoyed
the last few years both myself and my
staff enjoyed working with Linda Locke
of Louisville Kentucky Linda is the
executive director of coordinated
community childcare which we call four
C's and is also president of the
national child and adult care sponsors
forum four C's sponsors around fifty
childcare centers as a sponsor they
handle much of the paperwork and
administrative burdens of the center's
and homes and help train personnel for
all aspects of providing childcare in
summer they're extraordinarily effective
organization and I want to say to Linda
in advance I may have to leave before
you finish and I apologize for that I
want to thank you for coming and again
congratulate you for all you've done for
Kentucky Thank You senator appreciate
your comments I want to thank you and I
want to thank Senator Harkin both for
the privilege and honor of being here
today we're excited that this committee
is also focusing on the issue of very
young children in nutrition programs
particularly the child and adult care
Food Program we talked about school
lunch and we talked about school
breakfast we talked about WIC and there
is a big gap in there and a child and
adult care food program is meeting the
needs of our very youngest children so
we appreciate and are excited that you
all all are focusing on this area at
this time and particularly during this
reauthorization the national child and
adult care Food Program sponsors forum
represents the ten thousand Food Program
sponsors around the country providing
food service to nearly two million
children every day most of these under
the age of five years old want to thank
the members of the subcommittee and the
full committee and you to Senator
McConnell for what you've done on the
demonstration project in Kentucky we
appreciate the work that you all have
done to improve the nutritional status
of young children we also appreciate
Senate bill 161 for and lynn woolsey
spill in the house HR 3582 which all
contain improvements in the child and
adult care Food Program and particularly
making permanent the demonstration
project that was implemented in 1989
through
the efforts of the subcommittee and
Senator McConnell I've submitted my
written testimony which details the
vehicle vital critical role that the
food program prey plays in providing for
the good health and well-being of our
nation's youngest children I'd like to
spend the moment to talk about the three
types of programs for the child and
adult care Food Program provide services
to the first is family child care homes
this is nationally Devine defined as the
care of six or fewer children in the
home of the caregiver thousands of
family child care homes throughout the
country and particularly the child care
delivery system in rural areas and in
many low-income inner-city areas child
care centers in the child and adult care
Food Program these are comprised of
nonprofit Centers for profit or title 20
centers as they are noted in the Food
Program and the Head Start centers the
program also serves adult day care
programs I will confine my remarks to
the two types of child day care programs
our family childcare and center-based
care though my testimony refers to other
programs too I'd like to make a few
points about children in child day care
most children spend 10 to 12 hours every
day in child day care preschool children
receive between 75 and 80 percent of
their daily nutrition while in care 34%
of children under the age of 5 who are
in a formal daycare setting are in
family child care including the majority
of infants and toddlers so when we talk
about reaching young children and
working with families family childcare
is out there doing that that is
providing the role model that you talked
about because the provider many times
it's the person who's providing the
assistance to the younger parents and in
terms of that grandmother support that
you were speaking of Senator Harkin
because of our understanding of the cold
relationship between good childcare and
good nutrition the sponsors forum has
detailed its recommendations into four
categories within the testimony
my remarks to only a few of these
recommendations first the national
sponsors forum strongly believes that it
is in the best interest of the children
served by this program to maintain the
current reimbursement structure for
family daycare homes throughout the
early 80s and 90s national studies
showed the invaluable dual role that
this program played in both developing
quality family childcare and assuring
nutritional well-being of children that
they served just a few weeks ago the
Family and Work Institute study of
children and family childcare found that
regulated providers who receive the
highest quality scores 87 percent
participated in the child and adult care
Food Program another strong link between
this program and high quality childcare
any attempts to change the current
structure of this program will have
serious long-term consequences beyond
the loss of nutrition benefits the
adverse effects on accessibility quality
and safety of family childcare cannot be
overestimated the second recommendation
of the sponsors forum is to make
permanent the changes in the profit
Center eligibility demonstrated by the
Kentucky and Iowa projects these
projects were result of legislation
introduced by Senator McConnell in early
89 we are cooperating the amendments of
the 89 child nutrition reauthorization
bill through his leadership this has
made a significant impact the lives of
children in Kentucky current law allows
centers to participate if 25% of their
children are funded by Title 20 funds in
Kentucky and Iowa we're saying 25% of
the children must be low-income it has
made a significant difference because
title 20 fund has significantly
diminished in the states in recent years
the results of this project is shown
quite clearly that we are reaching new
low-income children that did not have
access to the food program before 56 to
57 percent of the children are
low-income we've seen significant other
improvements in the nutrition benefits
available to these kids
I would like to say in closing that the
suggestion and my testimony of ways to
expand the program the program are there
only if we are looking at not funding
any additional projects within
reauthorization our recommendation
continues to be that this program needs
to be made permanent it needs to be done
now and it needs to be done nationally
we certainly sincerely appreciate the
opportunity to be here today and offer
the services of our agency in the
sponsors forum as you work and through
this I certainly want to compliment you
and protect you really had me to success
to this program in the bill we're
talking about does make it permanent
although the expansions we don't know
about the funding for that we don't know
yet
I just want to thank you again Linda
it's good to see you again I'm going to
have to run I really appreciate your
coming thank you thank you very much the
San Miguel thank you miss hawk here for
your testimony I thank you all for your
for your very fine testimony Durrell Ian
I got it right that time
dr. Durrell Ian sorry Doris Doris okay
Doris
you focus basically on the classroom you
mentioned how hunger competes for
attention and children in school we've
certainly all seen that we've tried to
expand the the breakfast program in our
school systems around the country I
guess what I'd like you to expound on
just a little bit is the is the issue of
proper nutrition and diets in the school
lunch program itself
and whether or not there are to be any
changes in how school lunch programs are
are administered or run in terms of how
our children learn better nutrition now
that makes I to convolute let me dummy
cut to the quick on this I've been a
little upset over the past few years at
some of our school lunch programs and
how they're trying to emulate McDonald's
I like a McDonald's just about as much
as anybody in this room I can challenge
Bill Clinton eating McDonald's I can
tell you that and in moderation they're
not bad I'm not trying to say they're
not but and I say when I tender
emulating it I've been through
classrooms now where you know you have
nachos with cheese and you have
hamburgers you have all these kinds of
things that kids go through and eat and
I'm wondering if we're sending the right
messages now again the counter that they
say well if you don't provide that kids
will leave the school to go across the
street McDonald's need but I'm wondering
about that I'm just wondering if maybe
in our grade schools and stuff with a
little bit better education and we're
changing the way we present these foods
and stuff if whether or not we can't get
a better appreciation for more healthy
foods in our schools I just want to I
just wonder if you have any thoughts on
that because it seems to me we're just
as an observer and as someone who has
two kids and public schools I'm
concerned about the kind of message that
are being sent to these kids by the kind
of foods you're reading out there I have
several thoughts on that subject one let
me just say that as long as the school
food service remains a business
conducted on school property it has to
be a competitive business in order to
stay in the black which is what school
food service management is required to
do it is a it is a it is a business we
don't have a textbook business for
example run on the school campus where
the people who sell the textbooks have
to
have purchase of the textbook equal the
cost of the program etc so school lodge
is a business and when you're running a
business that is significantly under the
umbrella of regulation which school
lunch is it's very hard to be
competitive against the commercial food
service like McDonald's who has very
little other than food safety and
sanitation any like restrictions so what
school food service people have tried to
do is make menu items look like or be
like the things that unrestricted
commercial food service makes so
appealing to children they've done a
very good job at that one of USDA's
recommendations of course is to cut fat
and cholesterol and so forth what the
challenge to our members as dietitians
who are involved in school school food
service and other school food service
managers is to now keep the same kind of
menu item that is conducive to children
pizza hamburgers those format and try to
alter them in ways that still produce an
acceptable commercially competitive
product and meet the dietary guidelines
that we all recognize the school should
be emulating in front of children and so
it's a very tight rope that has to be
walked by the school food service people
and we talk about plate waste we're
concerned about the fact that children
throw foods away and if you look at the
quality of what it is that's thrown away
the very things that we think they ought
to be eating vegetables the fruits the
things that the whole grain breads I've
seen kids take the bread out and eat
only the stuff that's in the middle in
other words we are we are seeing the
plate wastes represent those things that
the school food service has included in
order to broaden the availability of
good quality so there's a number of
issues involved in that I do think that
one of our serious problems in managing
the Dietary Guidelines in schools is the
reduction of food energy because you can
get a very low-fat diet
that has been religiously prepared that
is now half of a number of calories that
a child needs and to be able to keep the
calories high and high enough a third of
it if you accept the RDA as the standard
a third of the calories which is around
700 for an eight-year-old kid for a meal
in order to do that child with no fat or
very little fat child has to eat four
slices of bread they have to eat a cup
of fruit they have to eat a tremendous
volume of food and that gets not only
expensive but in little kids just
impossible for them to be able to do so
we have to find ways to keep the
calories and energy high enough so the
kids still have the energy to learn and
at the same time restrict what we
consider to be the degenerative disease
related nutrients it's a very tough road
to hoe and I would like to see I mean in
my most facetious fantasy I see you all
regulating McDonald's the same way that
school lunches don't let a kid who's
under 18 eat that stuff unless it's low
cal low fat but it's never going to
happen and and tofu pizza that the
school produces isn't quite the same as
pizza and the kid knows it so Pacific
I'm not saying that tofu doesn't have
value and can't be used but it can't be
the protein of choice perhaps in a
burger or a pizza or whatever because
children recognize the same with with
with a prune with a chocolate chip
cookie we had a good friend of ours
convert a high calorie high fat
chocolate chip cookie into a low fat low
calorie cookie and they use prune whip
and we tested this cookie on a variety
of occasions what prune whip it's a it's
a material that has substance that has
very little sugar or fat and it extends
the cook it actually makes the cookie
look like a cookie the problem is we
call my pride of mr. German see there's
women and what happened is yes they
became a prune with cookie and the kids
said wait a minute wait a minute I'm
willing to eat this if you tell me it's
a prune whip cookie but if you tell me
this is a chocolate chip cookie
hang it up you know forget it
that's exactly what happened and that's
again the problem of pre creating menus
that have food items that try to
approximate what we want for our best
guess is what's the best meal and still
be competitive with what kids want to
eat and what kids recognized as being
foods that they're willing to pay for
and eat appreciate then senator the
Thank You mr. chairman
thirty years ago and in Indianapolis I
was elected to my first public
responsibilities member of the school
board and the issue for our board was
whether to have school lunches at all
this was a question whether federal aid
tended there were many communities in
the nation who had rejected all federal
aid so he came in from the beginning
with two arguments that are still very
similar the ones now free to kids later
the thing that I'm impressed with today
is the testimony that at least at four
of you that you're talking about the
whole child and the child is in the
school to learn and obviously has
problems doing that as you pointed out
to doctored relyon because of lack of
breakfast or low of energy or low
nutrition during the morning hours and
the tough subjects occur all kinds of
controversies what the child gets at
lunch if the child missed breakfast and
scalers has pointed out that these
children we're talking about in many
cases are obese at least in a relative
sense have higher body fat than they did
20 years ago or 30 years ago and what
I'm I suppose the like and some advice
and counsel from all of you is what kind
of input to any of you have with the
educational authorities because clearly
the children that are at most at-risk
children and poor communities of our
country are not achieving very good
results in the aggregates of our
remarkable success stories but we've
just gone through the ISTEP tests again
in Indiana and schools predictably that
would have a large number of children
failing to be even close to the second
grade level for sixth or eighth of
achievement are very frequently in
schools in which
the subjects we're talking about today
are most acute the energy level is the
lowest nutrition the poorest and lack of
parent involvement very low teachers
struggling but I've often wondered
starting with the 700 schools by apart
from the principle whether there is a
comprehensive view as to why learning is
not occurring these do two things over
which we may have some control nutrition
and exercise in school and what overall
comments do any of you have that would
be constructive if you were to try to
give guidelines to school administrators
I would just like to say that recently I
have been doing a great deal of work
with school administrators and school
administrator groups I would like to say
that up until the last few years we and
especially the last couple of years we
have been trying to use nutrition and
school feeding as a nutrition and long
term health issue and I have to tell you
that most school administrators that I
talk to don't care about health it is
very low on their priority of the issues
they make decisions about school board's
superintendents principals so when
you're talking about instituting a
program or doing promotion kinds of
things to get more kids involved in
these we finally now can talk about
achievement all principals are
interested in the competitive nature of
national testing and how their school
kids do on nationalise achievement test
scores we can talk to superintendents
about attendance and tardiness and
issues that have to do with
reimbursement for average daily
attendance etc we're finally coming into
an area where we have some quantitative
information that seems to be seductive
to the administrators and we have to
start forming our arguments in that
context rather than and I blame
nutritionists to some degree on was part
of this convincing them that they ought
to do something so when children are 50
they won't get osteoporosis well it's a
good idea but most superintendents are
so busy with what they need to do right
at this moment but that wasn't a very
convincing argument so I think we can
now change the nature of our argument
put some numbers behind it and be a
little bit more influential in having
them accept what it takes the energy it
takes to get these programs more fully
utilized and I hate to say this but my
name
in town just turned down breakfast a
whole breakfast program and they have 96
percent free and reduced price and they
refused it in the interest of protecting
family values and I got to tell you that
I think offering school breakfast
supports family values it gives families
who care about their kids another
opportunity of access to getting that
kid fed it seems to me the school
breakfast program could be viewed as one
of the most potentially
family-supporting options that we can
offer and yet the community that I live
right next door to I was out of town
unfortunately I couldn't get to the
school board meeting but I I will be at
the next one and and and that's exactly
what we see people are looking at added
as a reverse instead of what how it
might be viewed and all of these
arguments I think now need to be added
to the hopper to be more convincing to
school personnel I'd like to add to that
of something that I see as a potential
that we've worked with in the southeast
and that's working through the national
food service management Institute in
Mississippi and with our regional food
and nutrition services people in Atlanta
we've had some contracts related to
particularly for children with special
needs but it sort of applies to the
whole and I think that that this is sort
of it the way to get in for those of us
that are not within the school systems
and and we certainly feel that one of
the functions of the UA peas for example
is to make sure we're doing appropriate
community outreach and getting on to
those various committees and boards to
begin to make some kind of impact but I
think that the national food service
management Institute is a real key
player in all of this thank you mrs.
Laura slaw thank you and my
understanding of the question may not be
as clear as it should be and I was
understanding that you wanted to look at
how we can get children more involved
with good nutrition within the settings
in which they're in and particularly get
the schools involved in assuring that
that happens as well as all of you
involved in the argument yes certainly
one of the things I'd like to say is
that we have so many of these children
and childcare programs before they ever
school and so many of these children as
we know from research that their
physical development their cognitive
development eating habits etc so much of
this is developed at a very young age
and by the time they get to school there
is already set patterns we've asked
within our testimony for a set-aside
within the net program because we feel
that that is one of the very keys in
particularly with young children and
certainly within our children within
school to developing good eating habits
and a set aside for the CACFP and net
funding would help us get nutrition
training education and training down to
very young children to the providers and
to the center people who are providing
the care for those children to help them
develop the eating habits that they need
we think those because we have those
children for such a long period of time
then carries over into the family
setting I'd like to add to that there
I've seen a couple pilot programs that
are working quite well that are
incorporating teaching children about
good nutrition as well as teaching them
out their body and health I believe one
is in Fairfax County what they're doing
is incorporating in the curriculum why
the school lunch program is useful I
mean the kids will go in there and
they'll have like tastings on all these
different types of foods and then
they'll learn about the carbohydrates
and the fats and from what I've talked
to the teachers is actually rubbing off
the children actually are learning that
yes this is good food and yes then they
start actually eating it on the program
I saw in Fairfax started I think in
second graders and goes up to elementary
school but and again cycloid I said
before education I think is key food
what you eat is I wanna say I learned
saying there was a really nice study I
saw that had children who were put on a
very high salt diet a very sweet diet
and then a diet that had a was high in
fat they went on the side for about six
weeks and at the end of the program they
said asked each child you know what did
you like best
of course they liked what they were
eating salty kids like salt the sweet
kids like sweet then they switched it
and they had the kids change in those
salty kids ate sweets and the sweet kids
ate
and whatever in the six weeks they like
what they just ate so what we need to do
is educate them and also provide those
foods and reinforce them I mean have
them bring things home to their parents
in the program I said in all honesty it
was they really had to get the classroom
teacher involved they had to get the
food service people involved they had
the PPA involved but it worked and I
think it's all encompassing and we have
to hit it from every side we can't let
the food service people be stuck there
all alone or no one's going to buy it we
have a vote on we have nine minutes left
I'll turn the senator Craig before we
hit dismiss this panel well thank you
very much mr. chairman I appreciate all
of your testimony I think was very
balanced and that's what I appreciate as
we look at this issue a doctor I've kind
of had a running dialogue with Ellen
Haas about fat and it's been my
frustration from the beginning that what
she originally proposed I didn't think
would work very well because fat is a
tremendous source of energy and we do we
know that and I and yet at the same time
I struggle with what the Chairman is
concerned about about these food
programs might appear to be looking like
McDonald's or in fact like McDonald's
and striking that critical balance so
that the food in the lunchroom or in the
school food service program looks just a
little bit like the food the kids are
used to eating because I think miss
Locke you've already said those those
habits are and patterns are pretty well
established by the time the child gets
to the school program and while we can
use the program to teach and to
establish some new habits
I am intensely concerned that we use the
program to feed kids and that they go
away healthier better fed and striking
that balance becomes increasingly
important recognizing our time and the
vote
I guess that's more of a statement than
it is a question but if any of you would
wish to respond to that as brief as you
might I would appreciate
I'm willing to take always to two things
I'd like to address just very quickly
and one is that the balance is so
fragile that concentrating on fat per se
at the expense of total balance is one
of the pitfalls if the pitfall adults
have when they're making choices about
food intake the balance I have seen so
many women say I'm never going to drink
any more dairy product so I'm never
going to eat any more meat and at the
same time when you look at the source of
fat in their diet that's a very small
source compared to things that are much
less nutrient dense than meat or milk
and much better in terms of the
contribution of fat to their diet better
meaning it's such a larger portion and
yet the trade-off seems so seductive I'm
going to use that word again if I don't
want to be bothered with breakfast I can
certainly eat something in a bag with my
coffee and whatever in other words the
trade-off is very delicate even when
you're in control yourself
so for schools and for children to focus
on a single nutrient and almost at the
expense of the total picture of foods as
its presented in real life I think
undermines the behavioral possibilities
that children have real life is real
life they're going to have to choose
once in a while I'm adult but not every
day so why shouldn't they have a full
range of choices within the school
system I agree with you completely that
that we have to get food into kids thank
you one comment related to that too
because I agree with Doris that we have
sort of a fat fixation in our society
today and dietitians are always asked do
you really eat that doesn't have too
much fat you know and and we spend a lot
of time explaining that we're human
beings who sometimes go to 31 percent of
fat of our calories from fat rather than
just 30 but there's something we haven't
touched on as much in this panel is I
feel we should have related to the fat
issue and that is as we think about
school food service or anything from we
have to think about the parent the fan
we heard a lot of that earlier I don't
and we also today have to think a lot
about cultural sensitivity or cultural
competence or and many cultures eat more
fat than we do so we have huge barriers
to when we make these guidelines then we
you know just implementing the
guidelines becomes more complicated
because of the consumer is going to be
following those guidelines so we tend
sometimes to make situations more
complicated than they really need to be
but I also want to put in one more plug
about some of the children with special
needs that are going to be in those
schools that do not need to have their
fat cut down no we're concerned about
calories we don't want to go under 700
for the child with cerebral palsy we may
be wanting to go up to 900 but I get
there you've probably got to have a
little fat with you if you don't do that
you're going to have these huge volumes
these children can't handle volumes
anyway so you know it becomes a
complicated situation and it needs a lot
of attention and it needs a lot of
services built into it because
frequently these children need the
families need counseling but please
let's don't forget the parents in this
whole process how the heat catch on we
only got about three minutes ladies
thank you very thank you a subject will
recess here for about another ten
minutes we'll come back we'll have our
last panel thank you all very very thank
you I mean I
the subcommittee will resume its sitting
would call for a third panel mr. dan
Cooper with the iowa department of
agriculture miss alice Lenihan chief
division of maternal and child health
nutrition services section from Raleigh
North Carolina
miss Linda Lazarov a Vanderbilt
University School of Nursing from
Nashville Tennessee is Carol Porter from
kid care incorporated Houston Texas
accompanied by Mr Hunt Porter or first
Hartzler sorry Oh Carol Porter's husband
okay good okay glad to have you all here
I and again as I've said it earlier
panels we have your written statements
will be made a part of the record in
their entirety
I would ask again I apologize all these
interruptions we may have another one
here very shortly but that's the way
life is around are usually not on Friday
though so if you could just summarize
your statements for me and tell me what
you think would be most important for me
personally now and for the subcommittee
members in the written statements to to
take away from this hearing I'd
appreciate it
with that we'll start first with Dan
Cooper with the Iowa Department of
Agriculture administers the WIC farmers
market program and Iowa also currently
president of the National Association of
farmers market nutrition programs
mr. Cooper welcome senator Harkin thank
you very much and I thank the committee
for taking the time for hearing this
testimony and also for allowing me to
testify the WIC Farmers Market nutrition
act of 92 public law 102 314 was signed
into law in June July 2nd 92 with the
passage of that bill ten states became
part of the new astute assist
program operated by USDA however it's
more than just a food assistance program
it is also a program one of the most
successful market development programs
in this country it prevented it benefits
two distinct constituency group to the
at-risk clients who participate in the
WIC program and small horticultural
producers who rely on the direct
marketing of produce through farmers
markets in our country in 1993 one new
state North Carolina was added to the
ten which brought the total to 11 and
this past spring
there were several new programs added 13
states the District of Columbia and the
Indian nation of oklahoma bringing the
total to 26 programs that are now
participating in the farmers market
nutrition program every state has a
success story but that's the beauty of
the program is their success stories all
over the country I want to relate just
one in Iowa there was a farmer in one of
our markets who found that in selling
his apples that the WIC clients having
the voucher with them didn't seem to
quite understand what they do with this
huge bag of apples that they were about
to purchase especially with young
children so being frustrated by not
gaining any sales from the whig client
they went home and that week prepared a
recipe for applesauce and brought it
back and prepared it based on the five
pound bags of apples they had for sale
the next week they sold out of their
apples and what it has shown to us that
many of our producers have gained new
marketing skills by simply providing
information that's necessary for the WIC
population to utilize the products that
are available at the market I want to
tell you that in Iowa we found that 95
percent of the WIC clients had not
shopped at farmer's market prior to this
program and that 75 percent of the
clients were unfamiliar with lot of
farmers market even was now we found
that well over 70 percent indicated that
they attended a market after their food
benefits were exhausted or supplemented
their purchases with cash we also find
that many have indicated through our
surveys that those that come with them
either other family members friends
neighbors also have added to the
purchasing going on at local markets
throughout Iowa and the rest of the
country in a recent study by the
National Cancer Institute we reported
that people who eat four or more
servings of produce daily are diagnosed
with half the number of cancers than
those who consume 1 or less servings the
University of Connecticut found in a
recent study of participants in the WIC
Farmers Market nutrition program had
increased their consumption of fruits
and vegetables by over 50% in 1993 over
500,000 WIC clients received vouchers
for fresh produce under this program and
over 4,000 farmers at 650 markets
participated this current market season
found a total request for funding
exceeding the authorization level by
approximately four and a half million
dollars it is our hope that the
reauthorization of this program will
allow for a 1995 authorization of 10.5
million dollars and that the
Appropriations Committee will look
favorable upon that request with the
number of new programs established the
pressure for expansion dollars in this
program as well as in WIC and all other
programs will continue to grow rapidly
one of the added benefits of this
program has been the expanded
appreciation I think by the farm
community of a new a new group of
shoppers I don't think many of our fruit
and vegetable growers knew what was I
don't think many of our fruit and
vegetable growers understood the
nutritional at-risk population in our
state alone 27% of the children born are
nutritionally at-risk which is
phenomenal to me when it comes from Iowa
supposed to be the heartland where we
feed the world
and yet we find that in our own backyard
but it has created new relationships
between the populations we also find
that this committee and Senator Leahy
staff has been very helpful in
supporting this program and I want to
leave you with one thought from Charles
Willie president of the New York Farm
Bureau rarely has a government program
done so much good for so many people at
such a modest price because every dollar
expended stays in the local community to
help the WIC client to help the small
farmer and the local economy I thank you
very much for the opportunity and I'll
leave it at that Cooper thank you very
much for your testimony for being here
today and for your leadership in the
farmers market nutrition programs it has
been a great success
next Alice Lenihan I pronounced that
right yes sir
Goode is the chief of the division of
maternal and child health from Raleigh
North Carolina and his current president
of the National Association of WIC
directors welcome and please proceed
thank you
Thank You mr. chairman for the
opportunity as you said I'm Alice
Lenihan I am the WIC director for the
state of North Carolina I also am the
director of the farmers market nutrition
program our agency the State Health
Department operates the WIC Farmers
Market project in North Carolina I'd
like to commend you mr. chairman and
members of your committee for your
enthusiastic and continuing support of
the WIC program and your interest in the
welfare of our nation's mothers and
children with your permission I would
like to submit for the record in
addition to my written testimony a copy
of our 1994 legislative agenda and for
policy papers which are attached we also
have made available members of the
committee the Texas WIC News which
celebrates our 20th birthday and gives a
biography about WIC program in every
state and Indian nation and that will be
available for all the committee members
objection the your legislative proposal
will be made a part of the record and I
get a copy of that book oh thank you
Thanks
1994 as was said earlier marks a
milestone for the WIC program we are
celebrating the 20th anniversary of WIC
what started as a small pilot project in
Pineville Kentucky in 1994 became a
multi-state project by the end of fiscal
year 94 with a budget of ten point four
million serving approximately eighty
eight thousand participants now which is
a program serving six point five million
participants with the fiscal year
ninety-four budget at 2.8 billion
operating in over 8200 clinic sites
throughout the United States and its
territories America's mothers and
children who have graduated from the WIC
program have much to thank your
predecessors and many of you who are
still in the Senate I would like to
commend five members who are still in
the Senate who were members of the
original Select Committee on nutrition
and human needs who were the forefathers
of the fathers the Godfather's I'd have
to say Oh the WIC program Senator Leahy
senator Dole senator Kennedy senator
Cranston and Senator Hatfield they are
all part of the founding group of the
WIC programs quick is a prevention
program that works numerous private and
public sponsored studies of WIC have
demonstrated that it is a highly
successful program that has achieved
significant positive health consequences
and in health cost effective manner
yet in spite of the funding increases
for WIC over the past several years we
still fall short of reaching all of
those mothers infants and children who
are at nutritional risk and eligible for
the program President Clinton in his
budget and through incentives in his
health security Act has proposed funding
increases for WIC iearned every member
of Congress to support the president's
efforts to fully found WIC and to help
place all of America's children on an
even footing to face the future as
Congress considers the full funding for
the WIC program we urge you to maintain
the program's focus on nutrition its
reputation for providing quality
services our ability to tailor and
target and to exempt wit from all budget
cutting resolutions as I said we have
several legislative agenda items and I
would like to key in on some critical
ones we encourage Congress to use to
allow it to use the same definition of
family size currently in use by the
Medicaid program in the Medicaid program
a pregnant woman is counted as a family
of two automatic WIC income eligibility
is currently as
they're available to those participating
in Medicaid however many states no
longer have Medicaid or they no longer
call it Medicaid instead they are
developing federal and state supported
health care programs for their residents
the income levels established in these
plans may differ from the income levels
established for Medicaid eligibility and
potentially could create a double
standard for income determination we
also recommend that pregnancy for
low-income women should be considered a
nutritional risk in and of itself the
state of pregnancy requires additional
amounts of nutrients to promote an
optimal outcome a particular concern to
the WIC program is a pregnant woman who
presents herself early in the first
trimester and does not yet have an
identifying nutrition risk factor the
denial of WIC benefits at this time
forces the woman to wait until a
nutritional risk factor has manifested
itself if WIC is to truly make an impact
on early prenatal enrollment and
pregnancy outcome pregnancy in a
low-income women should be considered a
nutrition risk factor pregnancy is time
limited and at best we have the
opportunity to provide nutrition
education and supplemental foods for a
good bit of the nine months if this
change were made our association also
encourages Congress to allow states to
breastfeed hope to certify breastfeeding
women up to one year after delivery
currently we have to do a
recertification check at six months this
proposal would eliminate the need for
the six months certification we could
take the time that's spent on that
certification check to spend time on
breastfeeding promotion and nutrition
education this is how we handle the
infant in the WIC program they are
certified for the first year of life
what we're asking for is to treat the
breastfeeding woman in the infant in the
same certification rules also in keeping
with a recommendation from the WIC
national advisory committee our
association urges Congress to authorize
States the option to use food funds to
buy manual or electric breast pump
breast pumps are a clear benefit for
participants they assist breastfeeding
mothers to continue providing mother's
milk for their infants in spite of
timing constraints or logistical
situations caused by employment school
or other considerations for those
mothers choosing breastfeeding breast
pumps reduce and so
times eliminate the reliance on breast
milk substitutes because I Harriet cloud
earlier mentioned special needs children
I do want to bring up the fact that many
of the children that go on to some
schools are graduates of the WIC program
we do a tremendous job of WIC in serving
special needs children however there's a
small glitch and the regulations in the
amount of supplemental foods that we are
allowed to give children and I'm
speaking particularly to children on
metabolic diets who need very expensive
specialized formulas we would like to
see a change in the regulations that
would allow us if states so choose to
meet all the the supplemental
nutritional needs of children with
special needs we also propose that in
the farmers market program the Indian
and Native American nations be exempt
from the matching grant requirements for
participation in the program
mr. Cooper did mention there is one
Native American group that is now
participating in farmers market however
for the majority of the tribes this
match becomes a barrage they are
participating in the program in
conclusion I would like to thank you mr.
chairman for the opportunity to testify
in the National Association of which
directors look forward to working with
you and members on the committee thank
you very much and I look forward to
working with you miss on and on as we
get this legislation moving through next
we will hear from back to my
introductions here Minda Lazarov the
research associate per new chair center
to prevent childhood malnutrition is on
the faculty of the Vanderbilt University
School of Nursing in Nashville Tennessee
this last Rock welcome to subcommittee
thank you on behalf of nurturer I thank
you for this opportunity as a consultant
for the WIC program
I just recently conducted a series of
focus groups with Tennessee WIC women
and through this project I've heard
testimony after testimony of the very
valuable lessons that these women have
learned about feeding their children we
in WIC have clearly gotten our messages
across that what and how a mother feeds
herself and her children is a very
important responsibility of parenting
today I'll address the need to increase
the WIC program funding
breastfeeding education and support and
first I want to thank you for the vision
you supported four years ago a vision to
transform the infant feeding services of
WIC from primarily an infant formula
distribution and support program to a
program recognized nationwide for its
breastfeeding education and support
services few of us ever realized the
potential a designated portion of the
WIC grant would have for the first time
in many years WIC has witnessed an
increase in the rate of breastfeeding
this is particularly noteworthy when you
consider that WIC women are among those
women that are least likely to
breastfeed they're young they're exposed
to many myths about breastfeeding and in
general they just lack the confidence
oftentimes to believe that they can
breastfeed the impact of the eight
provisions added in 89 to strengthen the
WIC breastfeeding efforts has been
demonstrated most dramatically in
programs where the rates of
breastfeeding had been monitored for
several years and I kind of hate to use
a Perot ism here but I think this
picture does paint a thousand words this
shows you the change in rates of
breastfeeding in Tennessee and from 84
to 89 this point to this point we tried
a number of strategies to try and
increase the rates of breastfeeding and
then in the late 80s we had some money
where we were able to look in five sites
in Tennessee and determine exactly what
works to encourage women to breastfeed
we did not have the money to expand it
statewide though and so when the new
reauthorization in 89 was passed and we
got the funding we were kind of poised
and ready to go and were immediately
able to translate this statewide and
within a year we turned the rates around
as you can see it continues to go up
what did you do what made that happen
what made this happen
we hired peer counselors we've talked
about peer counselors early on maybe
I'll show this room no I think you can't
this camera right here respect enough
okay just point right here they trying
to switch that thing around and anyway
we had peer counselors we hired
professionals to assist WIC women and
spend some time during pregnancy
discussing why they should breastfeed to
help them sing they could adapt it to
their lifestyle to help them know that a
lot of the misconceptions they heard are
not true that they can
so primarily was just providing the
support through peer counselors and
professionals we've also seen much
evidence of success at the local level
as well in August a Georgia
breastfeeding rates have risen almost
threefold Moberly Missouri a third
increased Newark New Jersey rates have
increased threefold Cuyahoga County in
Ohio almost a 50 percent increase so
we've had lots of success in lots of
places and we've learned in general the
time with WIC patients translates into
more women choosing to breastfeed
district over the last four years yes
the last four years we've done a lot
with that money that we designated in
1989 the jobs not yet done them despite
the overhaul that has occurred in WIC
the change has not been consistent from
state to state from clinic to clinic or
from patient to patient within each
clinic consequently mothers in one
clinic may be given adequate education
and support while a mother just a few
miles away served in another clinic may
be given little support and I saw this
real clearly in the focus groups I
conducted wherein one in particular were
three women who had apparently been
given good support and said that WIC
made all the difference in the world
they never would have breastfeed had it
not been for WIC got that support and
then another woman who looked kind of
dumbfounded so she didn't even realize
that what gave that support and it turns
out and probing a little bit further
that she was served in a clinic just 30
miles away and this is a scenario that
really exists probably in every state
let's contrast that situation to the
support women get for formula feeding in
the WIC program today and every day
every woman who walks through the door
of a WIC clinic is guaranteed she will
get what she needs to formula feed her
baby the formula and the education to
use the formula why aren't WIC women
guaranteed the same access to
breastfeeding education the answer is as
simple as it is complex because breast
milk doesn't come in a can
if breast milk came packaged in a can
and was stocked right on the shelf next
to a can of formula there'd be no debate
about reinvesting in breast milk the
half a billion dollars we now expend on
formula we would probably not even allow
the purchase of infant formula based on
the same premise that the WIC program
doesn't permit the purchase of
unfortified cereals that increase the
risk of iron deficiency we wouldn't
allow the purchase of a product that
increases the risk of gas
during test alone sections ear
infections diarrhea allergies
life-threatening inter colitis and we
could go on stated in another way
imagine we arraignment reinventing the
program and are able to dump all the
dollars spent on infant feeding into a
big bag you know the kind with the
dollar sign on it we've got this bag
here and we dump the half a billion
spent on formula the staff time
educating the patient using formula the
staff time assisting patients and
switching from formulas to formulas when
they have allergies diarrhea or other GI
upsets and then the dollars spent on
supporting women in breastfeeding
currently in this bag of money we have
approximately 5% of the money isn't
support while 95
that's the infant formula support
however without the formidable division
between the food and admin dollars we
probably would divide it up differently
than we do now even if we recognize that
every dollar invested in breastfeeding
support does not translate into breast
milk we would still invest more than 8
million we designated in 89 and probably
more than the 22 million dollars we're
now proposing so as we move to the next
reauthorization period given the
numerous advantages of breastfeeding
shouldn't we make it as easy for women
to adopt breastfeeding as we've made it
to adopt formula feeding recognizing the
constraint on the administrative budget
we've proposed a $21 per pregnant and
breastfeeding woman only 2.9 percent of
the administrative budget this is a
modest increase from the 2.3 percent of
the budget designated in 1989 basically
a difference of 1/2 of 1% in conclusion
with WIC reaching its 20th birthday
perhaps it's time to re-examine why we
were debating over 1/2 of 1% of the
administrative budget for this critical
service in 74 it was understandable for
WIC to make a large investment in
formula-feeding without considering the
ramifications for providing support for
breastfeeding at that time there was
little support for breastfeeding from
any segments of our society including
the healthcare sector to get to decades
later despite the well-documented
benefits of breastfeeding we still allow
the inevitable distribution of infant
feeding dollars to exist although we
cannot solve the problem overnight I
urge you to build a
build on the overwhelmingly successful
vision created in 89 by moving one step
closer to assuring that all WIC women
have access to breastfeeding education
and support thank you thank you very
much as we refine a couple of questions
those definitely get to our last
panelist here and that is Carol Porter
vice president of kid care the first
meals-on-wheels program founded in
Houston it's accompanied by her husband
hurt Porter jr. so Thank You mr.
chairman
leave it up to you to decide who goes
first hey I want to say good afternoon
it's indeed an honor to speak before
this committee and share our vision for
better tomorrow for our children we
thank senator kay Bailey Hutchison for
arranging the topic of the day and to
the Aunt Jemima brand division of Quaker
Oats for sponsoring the trip every media
outlet cries out the saga of over 12.5
million hungry American children now
Cape here the first meals-on-wheels for
children founded in Houston Houston
Texas that is is committed to ending
hunger around ending hunger among
children within this century by
empowering individuals and organizations
to develop our concept you may listen to
many throughout our great country who
tell you to allocate more funding to
build more prisons and more juvenile
detention centers the answer is not the
flood America with prisons the answer is
to inundate our low-income communities
with quality food quality education job
opportunities effective treatment
facilities and quality housing all of
these issues are successfully addressed
by numerous community-based
organizations we can invest in creating
successes for our children now or we can
pay for the failures of adults later
case care delivers over 18 thousand
meals monthly to the door of Houston's
hungry children we also provide cultural
opportunities such as tutorial and day
care preschool and summer camp
experiences all of this
is done without governmental financial
assistance pet care daily assist over
500 children of every race because
hunger and malnutrition do not
discriminate and neither do we we have
achieved our success because of caring
individuals such as normal an individual
who was a reporter for a khou-tv channel
11 and a corporation such as Toys R Us
art line communications a Quaker Oats
Company and Houston central industries
now these corporations have demonstrated
how communities can change from
bleakness to brightness when the private
sector joined hands effectively with the
non private sector and nonprofit
organizations hunger in America is at an
epidemic proportion a meals on wheels
for children in American communities can
help reach the children that the Food
Pantry networks and Kids Cafe aren't
able to assist as well as children in
households receiving food stamps which
run out in the second or third week of
each month in communities throughout our
great country children are seen eating
out of dumpsters children are seeing
begging on our streets heart-wrenching
scenes remembered by those who
experience the Great Depression if our
government continues to fail to make
children the number one item on our
agenda if government fails to strongly
encourage private sector to join hands
with nonprofit organizations that
America has condemned the children in
need to an inheritance of a diminished
destiny our inaction will affect the
quality of life not only for the
children we fail now but also the
children of generations to come kid care
has been brought to municipal court
twice by our health department and face
a jury trial in September and October
because we refuse to use donated funds
to convert our home kitchen to
commercial standards allow me to share a
few of the examples of which we have
been cited for No Mas think our
preparation sink is too shallow I'll
stove lack the vented hood to minimize
grease fires since we never fried foods
this is an
necessary expense as a registered nurse
we are not saying lower the health
standards we are saying it is time to
modify the standards and make a
distinction between a non-profit and a
profit-making kitchen thereby enabling
mr. and mrs. community to fully
participate in feeding hungry men women
and children without fear of litigation
the government cannot feed the millions
the government needs the assistance of
every willing citizen and organization
we would appreciate any assistance in
facilitating change instead of statues
that impact nonprofit organizations
seeking to feed hungry Americans you mr.
chairman with a stroke of your pinned
word-of-mouth can help to change the
lives of millions of heavy American
Americans we no longer have the luxury
of saying let someone else do it because
we are that someone else we appreciate
the opportunity to present this
statement and are willing to assist this
committee and implementation procedures
thank you so very much
Oh mr. mr. Porter thank you very much
for being here and for the very fine
statement I mean just a couple things I
just wanted to clear up here let's start
with the beginning here because I had
some notes here mr. Cooper what
experience have you had either in Iowa
or other states with with WIC WIC
participants who have gotten these
farmers market certificates returning
what's the return aspect do people come
back they try it once to move on you
have any data on that well I think
almost every state has some kind of data
on that in Iowa what we find is they
continue I my statistics are probably a
little inaccurate here but I think well
over 55 56 percent of the constituents
in Iowa that received those benefits
continue to shop after they're no longer
receiving those benefits now if you
combine that with adding
- I think - their purchases I think it
goes up even during when they even have
their benefits goes up to something like
75 totally I can't give you national
figures on that however but by and large
we find that once they're educated that
this marketing opportunity or this this
shopping opportunity exists to get fresh
fruits and vegetables from people they
can talk to about how they were grown
where they were grown what you use them
for they continue to come back time and
time again and shop and we've seen in
our local communities in Iowa that the
markets have been greatly strengthened
by this increase in participation by WIC
clients not only when they have the
benefits but after they no longer are
being served by the program what's the
biggest problem in farmers markets with
WIC programs with farmers mar what is
the biggest hurdle biggest problem you
think that we have to address or look at
if there is any way there's not anything
well there's several but I think the
biggest problem probably would be the
need for increased funding because we
have a greater demand than we can serve
in Iowa this past year the state
legislature provided an additional
thirty or twenty five thousand dollars
so that we could add five counties to
the program that we can't serve with
federal dollars and we're finding that
with twenty six programs and and with
the suggestion of no match by the Indian
nations that the demands on the program
are going to be very severe and as WIC
goes towards full funding that even
programs like in Texas where they're not
serving possibly a population in one
area fully by this program that more
state dollars are going into the coffers
that would be probably the major concern
that we have is is the need for
increased funding and all of us have
those needs the second one would be that
we're administering the program with a
very low administrative rate and that
makes it very difficult for us to do the
kind of job that we should do and we
would like to see that the Congress
allows a higher administrative right
than
we have thank you very much mr. Cooper
mr. Linehan I as he national director
president of the wick directors I
obviously I was interested in your
legislative proposals I just handed my
staff and I were a big YES on it but one
thing as you know I've been very
concerned about breastfeeding we talked
about Miz layoffs here I might combine
these two to viewing this one question
four years ago we made these changes I
think we've eight million dollars annual
amount that we put into this for
education and Support Services but still
the rates are still quite low and now
I'm interested in the rates that went up
there now that's an increase but I still
think the rates are still pretty low
nationally as more more information
becomes available on the benefits of
breastfeeding
I believe it's imperative that we move
ahead and I'm just concerned about some
of the features of the WIC program that
may tend to discourage women from
breastfeeding now you mentioned some in
yours think where's that piece of paper
ahead you mentioned some things here on
this on the recertification yes no I
think that would help huh we do believe
that would help because it gives the
message to the mother that we're
treating the mother in the infant's the
same and we do assessments on the
instant throughout the first year of
life but we don't bring them back to go
through the formal recertification
process and anything that would make the
mother feel like she's giving her baby
the extra benefit I think the
elimination of that six-month
certification would help how about the
one - the one-year be extended another
one year beyond one year I hadn't I
hadn't thought of that
to be honest many mothers do we near
babies by the first year yes the life I
think
- yeah yeah maybe that's not a factor
maybe that's not the fact I just threw
that out there
you also said any WD or just Congress
ministry to authorize state C option use
food dollars to buy manual or electric
breast pumps they can't do that now we
buy breast pumps now we use the
nutrition services and administration
funds to buy breast pumps out of the
breast feeding allocation the the money
for breastfeeding promotion I feel some
of the best money spent is on staff on
hiring peer counselors and on training
programs I think that's what you to do
that right miss Amanda said in many
states in the last four years have used
their their breastfeeding funds for a
mix a mix of that there have been a lot
of changes in the WIC program but we
feel that I feel the best dollar spent
is on staff but we also need what I'm
going to call the assistive technology
of breast pumps for women who want to be
able to use the pump during the day when
they don't have the baby yes yes when I
miss Lazarov let me just see here I had
a question about this yeah I didn't
quite understand your your written
testimony and you mentioned this I just
couldn't quite fall maybe in cleared up
to my mind you said that the cost of
providing a very basic level of care to
the WIC participant for both the
prenatal breastfeeding education and the
postpartum support is approximately $32
for pregnant and breastfeeding woman
then you say we proposed $21 for
pregnant and breastfeeding woman for
this reauthorization period why are you
wanting it cut in that well we've had
concerns aired by the WIC community that
the administrative budget is spread very
thin and these dollars come out of the
administrative end of WIC so it was just
an effort to try and recognize that
there are lots of constraints on with
directors and we had a proposal earlier
to try and encourage the use of rebate
dollars for breastfeeding so that some
of this money could come out of
food pot but unfortunately we you know
have not been able to proceed with that
so it really boils down to a division
between admin and food breastfeeding
comes out of admin and there are lots of
constraints so we've proposed something
less than what's the ideal just
recognizing that the political climate
within the WIC community it's not
necessarily feeling good about farther
earmarking so what are we spending right
now we're spending approximately twenty
four million dollars in a per person per
person we're spending well it's a little
bit more than what we're even asking for
in this legislation we just got this
figure last week and I think it's in the
it's around twenty two dollars per
person right now that what the had been
required was approximately eight dollars
but in in the figures that men didn't
mentioned as you can see many states are
probably spending two to three times the
required set aside amount for
breastfeeding promotion we know that
two-thirds of the states already
spending the twenty one dollars were
asking for okay but in those states
Missoni and where they are spending
substantially more do we have any
indications whether or not we have an
increase in breastfeeding I like know if
there's a correlation there the data is
really not available right now senator
but we can we can ask you can ask USDA
to make the data more readily available
we don't have all last year's
expenditure data collated and available
to us I will say your men to brought up
the point about the competition for the
dollar when you look at what has to go
on in the WIC program and that we're
setting aside a certain dollar amount
for breastfeeding it does make for
competition both in terms of staff time
in dollar as we fulfill all the mandates
and the things that the program needs to
do and this is what she's referring to
you two about the concern within the WIC
community if I may add another comment
there is another provision that we're
proposing that is that all state
agencies are required to document their
rates of breastfeeding so I think this
will help us four years from now as
weari address this issue we'll have a
better answer to your question about
has the money invested translated into
increase rates of breastfeeding we do
have data like we have from Tennessee
and from these local agencies around the
country that these dollars have been
used effectively but there is definitely
a lack of data in all state agencies it
just seems to me at this $21 per person
out is 2.9 percent of the administrative
budget and the administrative budget is
how much now for WIC nationally we know
today we know you're giving that
and what's the administrative budget for
the WIC program well anyway you say that
the $21 part to 2.9 percent of it a
modest increase from the 2.3 percent of
the administrative budget designated in
1989 I assume designated for information
and support huh well that's sure not
very much no it's not that's I guess my
point I'm just wondering if well I don't
know I think I think just subcommittee
ought to take a look at that we had to
take a look at the administrative budget
of wig and find out what it's all being
used for and to see just how much of
that can go into for pregnant and
breastfeeding women support for the for
the for the information education peer
counseling and support as a percentage
of that I mean you say it's 2.9 percent
is what you're asking for what would
happen if we went to 4% or 5% I don't
know I want to take a look at that and
see what the impact is on the
administrative budget well let's see we
have my staff says we have 600 million
dollars in the administrative budget for
WIC that's a slightly over half a
billion dollars well miss unhand me
since you're the head of this outfit now
would you maybe do some work for me and
help us find out we certainly can
because I know you agree with me that we
have to really start really emphasized
breastfeed you can do everything we can
I'm just trying to find out what's the
best
we do and I think the past years four
years experiences of the programs that
have taken on the new mandate and the
set-aside expenditure we hope to have
data that will be able to show you that
in fact breastfeeding rates have changed
and how much money each year in the last
four years more money has been spent on
breastfeeding promotion and I believe
we're making a turnaround however I
think we need to look at the world
beyond WIC as we promote breastfeeding
what's what's going on in hospitals
what's going on in education and
training of healthcare professionals
what does you talked about mass media
earlier we need to do a good job of
changing the attitudes of the American
public in my state of North Carolina
last year we passed a law we had to
amend statutes to allow a woman to
breastfeed in public this is your part
yes we recently New York State has
passed a similar law as has Florida
women were asked to leave public places
they were very discretely breastfeeding
and they were asked to leave public
places so our legislature last year
passed a law are there other states that
have laws like that
yes there are New York State most
recently passed a law within the last
couple of weeks but you can't breastfeed
know that you can I'm sorry where they
had to amend the statute right there are
states that still have long indecent
exposure it's the craziest thing I've
ever heard
yes Maggie I guess I wasn't know what I
want to say beyond the world of WIC
there's a lot of there's a lot that
needs to be done if we as a country
we're going to do a better job of
getting all women to breastfeed not just
the women in the WIC program
Waymon states allow Playboy magazine to
be sold and penthouse and they allow
people are Cades but they won't allow a
mother to breastfeed in public I would
have to say it was mind-boggling kind of
interpretation of the of the public or a
local local judge to say that this was
indecent exposure so you get the law
changed and then there's no question
about the fact that it is legal to
breastfeed in public I guess I just
never thought about that
I just wanted my wife and I broke the
law maybe we did I don't know it's not
in Iowa sir
I don't know and what was I like I don't
know I don't know because I know my wife
I mean we go to restaurants and she
would breastfeed but you can do it
discreetly I mean yes you can no problem
we go to a theater and do I mean justice
no problem we've had women call us and
say they were asked to leave the
restaurant because they were told it was
in violation of the health code no I
work for the State Health Department and
was able to get back to the restaurants
they know it's not in violation and it
was now we just did it you're right
you're absolutely right we've got to
change attitudes and and I've worked
very hard for a number of years with the
with the group the doctor a basil basil
to the pediatricians in this country get
them in all of their statements and in
their seminars and stuff to really get
their doctors to promote breastfeeding
them and they they're just changing its
changing hospitals the same thing nurses
nurse practitioners that type of thing
nurse midwives to get that information
out but I really want to take a look at
this percentage of the ministry budget
and I need your help and your input from
that to see if we could use more of that
obviously you have to be very careful
because you don't want to tear down the
structure I want to be very cautious
about that but if we can put more into
that and if it can be absorbed and we
can build on the successes we've had
over the last four years I'd like to see
if we can do that so give me some
thoughts on that man one comment down
sure I guess as we move toward health
care reform that we also look at how
breastfeeding can be incorporated to
that as it does save potentially
millions of dollars and so that's
another area I guess I would encourage
you to keep in mind well if you've got
some suggestions for me on that let me
know we just passed our healthcare
reform bill out of our art committee
yesterday senator Kennedy's committee
the first one that's gotten through a
committee
I'm not certain there's anything on
breastfeeding and there we have a
benefits package on preventive care and
maternal and child support care and
stuff but I don't think that's
specifically delineated but if you have
some thoughts any of you on how we get
this involved in our health care bill
please let me know so I can do some
things on it before it gets through I
say to anyone here who's in the audience
also if you have any thoughts or
suggestions on on how we incorporate
this in a health care bill okay and one
more time though I agree with Alice that
there are other areas that need to be
addressed in order to assure WIC women
are making an informed choice WIC is
still in a very unique position and that
we give out infant formula and for a
full year and so without adequate
education during pregnancy and the
support after delivery the mess the
woman is left with the message that this
is what the government and the Health
Department wants hard to do you know
giving that formula way is the loudest
message what can make most convincing
message one can make but all WIC
programs are supposed to advise and
consult with a WIC participant that the
best thing for their child is breast
feeding and I can only assume that's not
happening
I believe that's happening i from
everything I can see now again this is
always a problem I mean you know my
strong feelings about breastfeeding have
been fighting this battle now going back
16 years but again obviously there are
the cases where women for medical reason
or some reason cannot recipe I mean
there are those cases but man comment
that it's happening everywhere yeah
because I guess it's how you define
what's happening I think every WIC
agency is making a stab at this it's
just because of the limited resources
many WIC agencies are not able to really
adequately spend time with that patient
to balance the message that this does
make a difference in it you know it does
take time although not much time and $32
is not a whole lot to spend some time
during pregnancy discussing with that
woman what her concerns are about
breastfeeding and then making sure
somebody is there to support her
it cost $32 and that doesn't include the
cost of support from the hospital from
these other health care providers
because they do play a very important
role too that's strictly the minimum
level of care that which should provide
in order to assure we balance the
message that the distribution of formula
provides well I've had a long struggle
with this I am NOT anti infant formula I
am in terms of marketing in the ways in
terms of the marketing and an infant
formula manufacturers know my long
history on that on that score but it is
an option that people ought to have
available to them but I again I think
that I would be counted with adequate
education information on breastfeeding I
was the one who had backed using the
Tennessee model back in the earlier mid
80s on the rebate program and getting
the cost of the infant formula down we
cut the cost of formula down by 50 60 %
in some cases and some of them may say
was that wise did that house really
available and they can get it much
cheaper well I don't know it's always a
that is a struggle I still would rather
approach it from the standpoint of of
Education when a woman is pregnant peer
counseling ensuring that those health
care professionals to whom she turns her
doctors nurses that they also support
this concept of breastfeeding and I
think will make some great inroads in
that regard but it is it is a constant
problem mr. mrs. Porter now tell me 18
thousand meals a month and no government
no government money no government all
right you I got a note you provide
breakfast lunch or dinner or while we in
during the school year we provide
preschoolers do not go to school
I'll have access to head start which I
consider one of the best programs we can
let's start and then in the afternoon we
go back and give a kitty back sack to
the children who come from the school
and their siblings because how can they
study if they're hungry and this is all
being done through corporate donations
and mr. and mrs. community okay so let
me know anything that is is this year
round or just during the school year
this is year round kids like to eat
around okay okay now where's are you
take a meal out in the morning we taking
me a lot of these are the kids who are
neither in Head Start right but it would
some of these kids be in daycare centers
no no these are children at home every
school is at home we first started out
giving the after-school sakshat okay and
then it hit us one day what happens to
the little ones were not in a program
Head Start
day care what happens to them well we
went out we're not gonna do it to ask
who's left home and we found out that
while the brothers and sisters are
getting a free lunch they're not eating
it all all in those cases so now we're
doing two meals when we have the money
it's always a hot meal in the morning
but always a sack lunch
Quaker Oats and supported us Toys R Us
online communications and what we're
doing is getting the food out to the
child Monday to Friday we hope to
increase the fattening friendís
but right now money to fight in our
schools all across the nation I'm going
to let out many children are not
thinking about swimming pools and summer
vacations most children are thinking
about how they're going to survive until
school starts again now how low age do
you supply food we also because WIC I
love WIC is a registered nurse we feed
the pregnant mothers who are not only a
program because there are many mothers
or not I can't access it for whatever
the reason so the baby in the warmer
define is I define a woman who would be
eligible for your program who would not
be in the WIC we have illegal aliens
whose children are will be American
citizens who are afraid to access we
have mothers who are American citizens
who because of numerous siblings at home
do not have the time or the energy to
board the bus
go inside and wait one of the things
that we have said as well as a feeling
and as well as immunizations because
we're concerned with that too is that we
must bring health care we must bring
these services into the community on a
door by door basis in a community by
community basis until we do that we're
going to always be seeing mothers or for
example crack mothers are not just
insensitive why they don't show up
appointment they don't have the money
for the buses and who's going to watch
the babies it's not him hello mr. mrs.
Porter and talk about what we can do to
make access easier for the women in bed
she's speaking to someone's status isn't
a lien is not something that the WIC
program has to even be concerned with it
- I know but you see and I understand to
carry the child talking about it's a
fear of going some places but you don't
have to register or anything like that
know you don't know you don't feel you
don't hear it is fearful so when we find
a fearful parent as a registered nurse I
talk to them about WIC encourage them to
go to WIC and until they get on WIC
KidCare supplement their food needs
first of all we do encourage
breastfeeding because I breastfed so
that's the first thing on my agenda but
until that mother is into that program
we are their support system so we feed
many pregnant mothers on the ramp to a
child who's 18 as long as they're in
school now summer is out in Houston
Texas
do you provide into the formula I try
not to I encourage them to nurse and
when I see they're not
if we push the can in their face they're
not going to take out the breast you
know and so next week in Texas will be
gearing up so we will be looking at
22,000 meals
most of the cooking I do myself because
we don't have the funding source which
is okay what we want people in America
to recognize the government cannot be
expected to do it all it takes everyone
joining hands together to end the hunger
crisis that fold American children and
we don't have to go to third world
nations to see third world conditions we
have children in our communities in
Washington all throughout the United
States of America who are in depicting
scenes that we used to think only
related to third world a meals on wheels
for children spoken throughout the
nation from your seat will encourage
people corporations to say this is an
avenue a possibility that works because
the government cannot be expected to do
it all nor does the government have the
money
that's interesting how many staff do you
have to serve 18,000 my volunteers we
have four paid staff minimal salaries no
fat cat sellers I do not take the salary
we are averaging about 80 cents plus on
the dollar directly to the child so we
have a lot of volunteers a lot of
children assisting us in getting the
meals out and while we're here who's
minding the store my son and other staff
members and volunteers will get in for
that but it works that's pretty good
that's pretty impressive it's pretty
impressive so it's a meal in the morning
and the only the afternoon delivered and
that summer time to conserve energy
because of money and gas we do one
delivery so we're giving both meals at
one time as well as breakfast the Quaker
Oats Company this is what I mean mr.
chairman we've got to get corporations
to get involved in lowering the hunger
to testing Quaker Oats Company has given
us
hundreds and hundreds of boxes
vandermeyer Lorraine Phoenix which is
not a commercial but this is to show how
corporate America can make a difference
oatmeal so we will be distributing this
to our homes next week so there will be
breakfast and then they look to us for
lunch and then we have Toys R Us for
giving the school supplies many children
don't go to school because there's no
supplies we must make children our
number one agenda government must
encourage corporations to join hands
then and only then will children be fed
I agree with you on that I'm delighted
to hear about quake roses is an Iowa
based company I'm glad they're I'm glad
they're doing this it's a good company
well thank you very much I appreciate
appreciate what you're doing very proud
of you that's that's very impressive
maybe next time I'm down in Houston that
can take a leave here I encourage
everyone to see
take a look sure anybody else have
anything else to add before we Ori
adjourn this well thought I thank you
again all of you very much for your
attention to this your dedication your
involvement in in feeding our children I
guess I just close on what I started I
said I started this whole hearing by
saying this is hearing about our future
and it certainly is and I I think we've
had some good testimony today we'll be
moving the reauthorization bill through
very shortly hopefully sometime this
summer again we always look for ways of
modifying the program again mr.
supporter pointed out government can't
do it all and we're going to have
limited means we are under severe budget
constraints so we have to look at how we
really squeeze the dollar and make it go
as far as possible and to the extent
that we can involve the private sector
in some kind of joint operations and
joint to endeavors I think would all be
better off for that if we can get that
accomplished so if anyone again I throw
this out if anyone has if you have any
suggestions for modifications and the
program changes that need to be made in
reauthorization please by all means let
us know and we'll take it into
consideration
so again the subcommittee will uh stand
adjourned we really next have a subtitle
well we'll stand adjourned the I assume
the next hearing that we will have will
be on the school lunch in the school
breakfast program probably within the
next month sometime but you'll all be
notified thank you very much